happy friday everybody this country
seems to be on fire in a bunch of
different ways and that fire is burning
brightly today we have a
new story that apparently thirty 000
haitian illegal immigrants enter the
country a bunch of them are missing 17
000 are apparently being allowed to stay
and i guess what happens you get enough
of these people at the border the
government panics because the bad press
and says just let them all in just they
can do whatever they want just make the
pictures go away it's kind of where
we're at so you know what we're going to
talk a lot about that stuff because
we're we're hanging out with ed calderon
and you're you're an expert man you want
to introduce yourself
sure my name is uh ed um i worked for
the mexican government for about 12
years
doing counter-narcotics work working
against people traffickers
working against cartels
and specifically
kind of spending a lot of time and
experiencing the border on the southern
side of it you know
looking at some of these problems
firsthand
um currently we're working train people
across the country from border patrol to
fbi secret service
uh people who just want to be safe and
a lot of the things that i uh showcase
and kind of show people or
directly related to that experience that
i had down there so and there's
apparently like i don't i don't know if
this is too too off the beaten path but
you're mentioning like weird occult
stuff too like stuff that goes on down
there with like unsolved murders uh
i uh i do
training for law enforcement stateside
related to mexican occultism and
criminal occultism whoa so that's gonna
be fun we'll talk about that sure
you know basically showing them
you know the current versions and
symbology and and trends as far as santa
muerte
uh the veneration of malberte which is
like a mexican robin hood
to um to how some of these groups use
utilize some of these things in a
ritualistic fashion to
create fear in their enemies or to
initiate people within their ranks by
having them do crazy things like eating
somebody's heart you know right on well
that sounds like it'll be a fun
conversation
glad you're here next time
hey good to see you buddy uh ian
crossland happy to be here thanks tim
yeah i'm in the corner as well i was
just texting with one of my friends he's
like yo i'm at this class with ed
calderon and i was like oh that's crazy
because we're having him just next week
so i'm very excited to have him i'm
excited to hear what's going on on the
border i'm afraid it's going to be
depressing but i'm looking forward to
being informed but before we get started
my friends we have an amazing sponsor it
is you know you'll love them biotrust
today it's ageless multi-collagen you
see as an old man who likes to skate on
the half pipes i got rickety old knees
so i got to take this here ageless
multi-collagen supplement just go to
strongerbonesandlife.com and you can
secure your supply of ageless
multi-collagen up to 51
off today so collagen makes your skin
stronger better or looks look it looks
better i'm not going to pretend to be a
scientist or anything like that but it's
also in your joints your tendons your
bones so it just uh fingers fingernails
etc it's an it's a vital protein for
that good
good feeling especially as you're
getting old you need it and i'm again
not pretending to be an expert i know
that i read that men have twice as much
as calogen as women do so it's
definitely something you know for the
ladies if you want to get some just go
to again stronger bones and life.com and
you will get a 60-day money-back
guarantee the five key types of collagen
you need from four different sources
essential to optimally support an array
of full-body benefits for every order
today they will donate a nutritious meal
to a hungry child in your honor through
their partnership with no kid hungry.org
to date biotrust has provided over 5
million meals to hungry kids so please
help them hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year it is non-gmo free of
artificial colors flavors preservatives
and sweeteners free of gluten
antibiotics and rbgh and rbst nearly no
odor or taste unlike bone broth or other
collagen supplements there's no clumping
unlike other supplements you get free
shipping with every order free vip live
health and coach health and fitness
coaching from biotrust's team of expert
nutrition and health coaches for life
with every order and their e-report the
14 foods for amazing skin with every
every order so make sure you go to
strongerbonesandlife.com and again guys
shout out to everybody who's willing to
get behind us and support this show
it's a very difficult political
landscape so when you find you know
companies that are like look we're we're
cool this we're gonna sponsor a show
these are the companies that you should
be supporting other than these other you
know companies i'll keep it polite for
the sake of you know doing a shout out
but uh support the companies that
support us and allow us to do our work
but don't forget to go to timcast.com
become a member we got a bunch of really
awesome content journalists
we are set to launch two new members
only shows i believe by next week one of
them is really simple it's called the
green room
when guests show up we got people
hanging out in the green room we just
film it and so a lot of the conversation
is weird and you wouldn't expect it
because it's not particularly like
mainstream news might be talking about
just history
philosophy maybe weird sci-fi stuff and
just tv shows it's just fun
and the next one is our mystery show we
haven't released the name of it yet but
we do i believe have one episode done
already and we're ready to launch the
introduction of the show so it's going
to be really fun they will be on the
website and as members you get access to
all that extra special content
as you're at your current membership
rate so we're going to keep adding more
and more stuff to the best of our
abilities and don't forget to like this
video subscribe to the channel share the
show with your friends now let's talk
about what's going on in the news with
this border crisis we got the story from
the daily mail mayorkas admits 30 000
haitian migrants entered the us as del
rio campus finally cleared homeland
security boss doubles previous figure as
he revealed seventeen thousand four
hundred are applying to stay eight
thousand have been deported but two
thousand six hundred are missing now
here's the crazy thing apparently
there's a bunch of chilean and brazilian
ids yeah these guys have yeah so so they
were saying these are refugees like oh
no there's an earthquake in haiti
they're refugees what's happened here so
they're all they've already been given
refugee status by another country that's
why they have the ids which is an
interesting you know i i don't know i
don't know a lot about immigration law
here being an immigrant myself i did a
little research
but uh they are they were already given
refugee status by another country so
that's why they have those uh ids those
are part of their packages to give to be
given that status in those countries but
what
so you do you know the specific details
about why they're coming here just
economic migration
i mean so things are economically
they're pretty bad in a lot of places in
south america um a lot of a lot of a lot
of haitians actually stayed in mexico
for example and a lot of them were
giving given the refugee status in
mexico
um after trump lost the elections and
after biden came into power there there
was a
massive kind of like a
spike in
chattering conversations and some of
these face
facebook groups attached to the migrant
caravan groups that are out there that's
how they communicate
and the main narrative that was pushed
forth is that the doors are open come
now you were saying before the show
there's like massive networks of
facebook groups that are all like
organized just to get people across the
board yeah and it's interesting i mean
they're kind of automated like as soon
as something changes or shifts like
they're oh
don't go to tijuana this time
go to go through texas uh don't go to
don't go through california go to texas
now that's modern warfare yeah having a
bunch of network groups automated to
tell people
you know oh hey now now like to push on
a message that triggers a reaction and
then what happens is you got to think
about fourth and fifth generation of
warfare which you cite very often but in
today's den age you can't set a plane
with a bomber you can't send a fighter
you're going to spark an actual hot
kinetic war
but you can send disruptive forces you
can you can disrupt local economies you
can spread political ideology or you can
create a migrant crisis which ex
exhausts our resources yeah um
you you see
a script being handed out to these
people as far as what they need to be
what they need to say they you see uh
advice to people oh if you can't make
the trip but you have young children
have your children make the trip for you
so you can they later they can later on
claim you and chain migration
can happen how's chain migration work uh
if i'm uh you know if i get granted
citizenship i can then ask for my
parents to be also be granted um you
know so you can sponsor people
so if you uh uh as a legal citizen right
let's say you know somebody who lives in
the philippines
you could sponsor them and assume i
think it's 10 years of financial
liability for the individual and
it makes it substantially easier for
them to come not perfectly easy but
substantially easier for them so you get
these kids that'll come
the parents will bring their kids once
the kids are old enough they say i
sponsor my parents if if the person who
sponsored accrues any public debt then
the person who sponsored them has to pay
for it so you basically can just
is it easier to sponsor family than
friends yeah yeah yeah it's hard to
sponsor friends and a lot of these kids
that you see on the border that are
being smuggled over i mean they're not
they're not they're not voluntarily
taking the trip you know um
there's a few videos out there i've
actually posted some of those videos on
my instagram account which shows them
that are clearly being
i mean uh we had some medical
professionals comment on there i don't
know uh that's on my not my field but
i'm actually experiencing people under
the effects of things like hypno
wow what's it called uh
roofies
i've seen people under the effects of
that with the like lack of dilation so
so why do you think this weird stuff is
happening where they're giving out
scripts and they're sending out these
mass messages i mean it's it seems to be
like an organized attempt on on on just
moving a bunch of people into this
country that's that's and when i say
organized attempt
um i was in tijuana for the first
caravan when it hit there and it was
clearly organized people are being
transported organizers were being paid
in dollars
the camps were being set up in certain
places and were being completely
supplied and funded by people from
california driving down and giving them
supplies
with this current version of it you see
um
you see people waiting on the other side
of the border for some of these people
as soon as they cross and getting
basically distributed across the country
um you see people on the southern border
of mexico as soon as they cross
basically
catch them with buses and organizing
their transport on the way up so there's
a logistic there's a whole it's a whole
logistical process that's being
organized by somebody are they bringing
them from south america are they there
waiting to catch them when they enter
mexico i mean they are basically the the
whole advice that they're giving on some
of these social media groups is to amass
or organizing groups
it's safer for them right
different than it was with the last
honduran kind of mostly honduran migrant
caravan
one of the reasons they avoided going to
through the central part of mexico into
texas
was because most of the members of this
caravan were actually 18th street gang
members
which traditionally have a rivalry with
the thirteen uh mara salvatrucha people
so that's why they went all the way to
through california to avoid interesting
wow but these guys are haitians so they
don't have that that problem
well chilean patients they don't have
that problem so that's why they went
through straight straight into into that
uh that spot i mean
any ideas why they're trying to get all
these people to come to the u.s i mean i
know the people on the internet have a
lot of ideas i mean it's a it's a it's
an interesting way of disrupting your
you know
your economies or yeah i mean it's i
mean
if you have you have enemies abroad you
know you have you have people
um sending chemists to show cartel
groups how to make fentanyl in mexico
you know you have uh fentanyl-laced
heroin exploding all across this country
and it's being produced in mexico
uh and you have a cartel group in mexico
that is a that grew exponentially during
the cobit epidemic and the only reason
it did so was because it had access to
the pacific side seaports
and an open relationship with a supplier
from china so i don't that's what i was
going to ask china seems obvious it's
it's pretty
a lot of people in mexico that observe
these things closely and i and i have a
lot of friends that are still active
it's it's sort of it sort of feels more
and more like china planned our downfall
50 years ago and we're like catching it
at the last minute it's too late
it's i mean for for
for from my experience now looking at
some of these things progressing
you see this uh
use this new cartel down there the car
the
cartel cadiz
on the new generation cartel um
a lot of videos on them on social media
where they have all this military
equipment and they're raising their
rifles and stuff like that
um
they are expanding like a different at a
dramatic rate across the country and
people don't realize they can't figure
out how it is possible for these groups
to be expanding and they're like well i
mean they're a violent group and they
have connections in mexico and mexico
they have they're obviously a proxy
group for somebody externally and then
you realize that on the state state side
these criminal groups are using chinese
banking apps to hide their money to send
back to mexico
so wow and also fentanyl
just just the massive amounts of
fentanyl being brought into mexico and
now being produced in mexico
people say oh criminal groups in china
are
are smuggling it out
they're
that's not how china works you know that
there's not a secret chinese criminal
enterprise that doesn't doesn't
talk to the government out there right
you know it's
if it's coming out of china you know
chinese state knows about it you know
yeah
um
legalized weed
brought
fields of classically planted marijuana
fields turned into poppy fields in
mexico whoa
and somebody figured that that so we got
to legalize
opiates now so that the fields will turn
into what like i mean
so the heroin out there is not that
strong not like the afghani stuff
so they
laced it with fentanyl wow so they
legalized weed in mexico and then they
started planting opiates as soon as you
saw the legalization of wheat in
california some of the some of the crops
changed into poppy and this is around
the time of the prescription opinion
epidemic and how it was kind of weighing
down
and they were ready for something else
and that something else was
fentanyl-laced heroin and now the new
thing is
bogus pain medication laced with
fentanyl so now you're finding weird
pain press pill presses in mexico and
they're manufacturing something that
looks like a but this is killing their
own customers
that is the suspicious part of it yeah
classically cartels didn't react behave
that way seen a law cartel wouldn't
behave that way
but this is a new breed of
militarized narco insurgency that is
probably a proxy group of somebody
outside of the country china
i don't know wars come on who else would
it be they play the long game and i mean
the opium wars technically ended a
hundred and seventy years ago but i
don't think they ever ended they want to
get back you know yeah i heard that with
afghanistan that the taliban shut down
the the poppy fields but then as soon as
we came back in we started back up is
that true i don't know if that's true
but i i don't have any experience in the
middle east i do have friends that were
out there and they say that you know
that was part of part of the the actions
in the of the us and afghanistan was to
protect some of those fields wow there's
images of american troops in poppy
fields i imagined that they were real i
don't know
now you you mentioned that uh
when
legalized marijuana came to the states a
lot of these fields turned to poppy i
was down in mexico uh this is almost two
years ago now and i heard from a lot of
people that
when
marijuana became legal and they couldn't
make money off it they started just
hijacking avocado companies yeah that's
true that's a bit but well not just
hijacking but
paid protection
so mexico has a mexico has cartel groups
not just one they have several they have
a few big ones
but one of the ways they operate and one
of the ways they make money is not just
selling drugs or trafficking throughout
the u.s they also control a large local
giant drug market
and
abductions for ransom
and
paid protection rackets we recently had
somebody get a pipe bomb for their
birthday because he refused to pay for
protection in the state of guanajuato
protection from them from the cartel
from themselves yeah um so what you saw
with some of these avocado orchards and
some of the
auto defenses or the self-defense groups
that grew out of some of these conflicts
out there
they would go to an avocado or it should
say avocados in mexico and the industry
around them are just multi-million
dollar industries they're on trees right
yeah yeah but there's like a lot of them
down there and and they said i'd love to
have an avocado tree it'd be awesome
that would be pretty great
uh they uh
they said oh the there's a good
you know business you have here um it
would be ashamed if somebody you know
burned it all down or abducted you so
give us give us money to protect you
that's how it works
um and the cops there's no cops there's
no the
the cartels are the police so i mean
that's that in some some areas in mexico
so what's the difference they come to
you and say if you don't pay up we'll
we'll drag you out of your house at
gunpoint it sounds the same here you
know pay taxes and no i'm kidding not
paying taxes in the u.s is a civil
violation i guess yeah but i mean let me
ask you though if if the cartel shows up
and says
you're gonna pay us to protect you and
you say okay here's the money they'll
actually protect you from criminals and
yeah it's true i mean uh i had this real
experience of driving in on a road in
sinaloa that was better that was cartel
made better than the
public right of course so
uh during the coba epidemic you on the
news all you are not even on the news
just the social media you would see the
cartels handing out supplies to people
you know you would see cartel's
enforcing mask mandates in some cases if
we find you with all the masks outside
we'll go oh geez get to get you with the
board wow wow uh
that's one way to enforce a mandate so
they so they in a lot of ways they are
the government in some places i mean
there's no fly zones over some cities
because they will
put down your helicopter right wow so
yes they invade that's that's the thing
with mexico in the u.s as well
the u.s refuses to recognize that its
neighbor is not governed by a single
entity i mean not it publicly doesn't
say it it refuses to recognize that
mexico doesn't have a crime problem and
has an insurgency problem and it's not
fighting an insurgency group it's
fighting several narco insurgencies
which
meet every single part of a definition
of a terrorist group i mean if somebody
sends you a pipe bomb for your birthday
yeah
what is that group doing
yeah yeah if you don't pay taxes that
won't happen so you get a knock on the
door and some guy in a suit will be like
you need to pay your taxes and you'll be
like okay i'm taking you to court okay i
mean the amount
in kalisko alone has
somewhere around ten thousand people
that are missing
or or bodies that were found climate and
growth planets engraved so it's mass
graves are found in mexico wow so
because of cartels specifically
i mean who yeah cartel specifically
you're talking earlier about the juarez
killing fields i've never heard of these
until can you explain what those are a
little bit uh it's a phenomenon that
happened in juarez back in the early
2000s where you know basically women
were found murdered raped and
ritualistically killed in a lot of parts
in the desert on juarez mostly women
that worked in some of the maquiladoras
basically the large industrial plants
that work out there um
a lot of weird rumors around it you know
um
there was a lot of a lot of the media
and the government in mexico was saying
it was cartel related because that's the
easiest thing to say oh somebody died
somebody was killed he's probably
involved in the cartels that's the way
they just get rid of easy out 90 of most
of over 90 of all murders in mexico are
never solved so
you know it's a perfect place for
that at what point does a gang become a
cartel like what's the difference really
uh i mean a cartel specifically if
you're a large enough group where you
have influences and or
fear on behalf of the police towards you
yeah you're you're a criminal enterprise
if you have uh
if you tax people to start their
businesses where you uh control if you
are control of a drug route up into the
united states or if you traffic drugs
yourself i think you're kind of there
i i guess the
well the definition of a cartel has to
do with with merchandising manufacturing
and distribution
so i guess if you're going back to like
the old trope of the mafia that was just
the local group being like you're gonna
pay us so we're gonna smash your face up
or protect you you know protection
racket that's more like mob stuff
but uh with the cartels it's
specifically around the products and the
manufacturing and the distribution so i
guess a lot for a lot of drugs i think
specifically one thing i've always tried
to do is just tell people to realize
that these guys are defining themselves
now i mean it's a whole new definition
uh
you you have a country like the us that
wants to not label them no terrorist
organization
probably because of immigration well
trump wanted to send the army down
remember that yeah but it was i think it
was a pressure thing they did to mexico
to try to get them to enforce their own
borders right so
the real the i think the only reason why
you won't label them
the cartels a terrorist organization is
because now people fleeing from mexico
have a legal claim to asylum
because now they're leaving a
terrorist group that the u.s in some way
shape or form you know but the reality
is if they if they are acting like a
terrorist group then those people really
are fleeing yeah well i mean there's
whole towns ghost towns in mexico were
people that fled
cartel terrorism basically that people
that go ahead this is crazy to me like
is it self-destructive why i mean why
would the cartels do something that
would negatively impact the economy that
would that they want to benefit from i
yeah again this is
these groups uh get formed grow
leadership gets killed one cartel turns
into two
uh 40 year old cartel head is now a 25
year old guy after the other guy got
killed got killed
and it's it's a it's a chaotic it's a
chaotic thing we we talk a lot about the
covet stuff and uh not so i
i don't want to get into specifics of
covet but basically like a virus we've
talked about how
ebola is a bad virus in that it's so
extreme
that people become debilitated
or get quarantined or noticeably sick
and that limits the ability for it to
spread
and the the viruses that are quote
unquote good or successful are the ones
that your body doesn't react to so the
virus infects every single human
possible and flourishes and lives on
because it's not causing too much damage
i think about these cartels and i'm like
if you've got a town and people are
doing stuff you can extract you can
steal from those people but there's a
fine line right it's the goose that it's
killing the goose that lays a golden egg
and so you eventually find that you know
this story reminds me of or like is is
similar i guess into the to like the
virus they become so extreme they burn
out the area cause everyone fleeing and
there's nothing left to get and then
they have to leave there's nothing there
for any for them anymore yeah i mean
sinaloa the state of sinaloa and kulikan
specifically is a pretty good example of
you know how some of these cartels
classically operate
the mexican president went to sinaloa
and shook hands with el chapo's mom and
talked to his lawyer
and then later a few years later
two years later he went and did a
meeting with the local
poppy and weed growers like this
televised with the with the head of the
the of the of the security of the army
next to him and said
people are bringing fentanyl from china
and all these chemicals like what about
the poppy field growers and what about
the weed growers like what about us we
need to support the local commerce right
so that's great which president was that
this
he's way to the left
i heard that he does these things in the
morning where he comes out into his
balcony and like starts yelling to the
people
he does that every mexican independence
day what he does is i think all the los
mananos which is basically goes on a
rant for about an hour uh of different
subjects you know the last one was he
was demanding to
first to spain to to apologize for for
the conquest you know what when okay
when i mean it's i mean most mexicans
are a mixture of native and spanish
we're all kind of mixed you know yeah
like it's
it's a weird thing to kind of focus on
when the country's burning you know so
let me ask you about the border man um
when you heard this this large man with
orange skin and
swirly blonde hair say build a wall yeah
what was your initial reaction with your
experience at being on the border uh uh
the
the fence because it was a fence not a
wall
uh the the fence had already been built
up and was already kind of highly
secured in places like the border
between tijuana and san diego
and drug prices specifically cocaine
have been stable for 30 years so it
means that that doesn't realistically as
far as a safety feature for the united
states is a counter narcotic feature or
safety to keep the bad people out
isn't there like a point where the the
fence just goes to the water and you
just go around it yes yes there is and
there's always there's a bunch of border
patrol there and you know they'll
they'll tackle you if you if you try it
will they throw you back on the other
side or what no they'll they'll tackle
you they'll put you in a processing
center and then put you on a bus and
they'll be walked across san ysidro
probably in the few like right now the
way things are like it's the next day
yeah i think you know doesn't that seem
insane that like you're on one side of
the fence and you walk over and they
grab you and then do all of this crazy
administrative work instead of just
pushing you back and back get it here
yeah no i just want to grab you and
process you and then send you back which
is amazing drain of resources right um
another thing like right now during the
whole haitian
push into the
u.s a lot of the the
the checkpoints around the area that
were usually manned for counter-narcotic
interdiction stuff completely abandoned
and you you hear chatter on the southern
side of the border with some of the guys
that are you know crossing the border
not to migrate but the with loads on
their backs it's christmas wait wait so
us border patrol is not manning these
u.s border patrol abandoned most of
their post uh specifically some of their
you know some of their roadblocks that
they have and also some of the the
counter narcotic introduction stuff that
the
that they usually do in some places
uh a lot of these places where ghost
towns were abandoned because they were
all concentrated on that specific uh
border area
and also just hearing some of the
conversations here and some of the
people that i used to work with south on
the on the south side of the border
they're all saying it's crazy not be
that it's christmas you know are there
cats are away are they walking across
the board are they going through tunnels
are they sending drones all across all
of it uh uh is this i found one of the
first drones that ever
crashed in tijuana when i was active is
this is this administration
or just what i mean the border's open
the border is open the border's open and
also these massive immigration
influx into the united states put every
single most of your already outstretched
resources into a single spot which means
it's christmas for trafficking
everywhere else yeah
bullets and guns from the north to the
from the north to the south and cash
this country is being strangled out yeah
strangled
slow slow demise there's a pillow over
the face of america right now and uh
again it's it's
this border this border crisis is making
millions and millions of dollars for
people that are just waiting for the cat
to go you know to be busy somewhere else
you know this is
tunnels there's somewhere i mean
conversation
somewhere over 50 to 60
active tunnels on the border
i talked about fully submersibles way
back in the day nobody believed me about
those that was where we've been found
wait wait wait wait they're using
submarines
to smuggle stuff and people and uh
drugs drugs you wouldn't use something
as valuable as a fully submersible
submarine for people because then the
people have a tendency to talk you know
i came here in a summary
uh but yeah fully submersibles uh drones
uh like squadron of drones um catapults
small
capital oh i heard these stories they
launched them over the trebuchets
that's the first time i when i saw one i
saw one in mexicali
and
i saw and i was like that's a trebuchet
like how do you know that word i watched
about it kpbs
i think i learned about them and so
they're flinging drugs over they fling
drug loads over they uh rc cars electric
control remote cars rc cars just speed
out there uh drones tunnels um people
that have border crossing cards like
there's a sentry program in place like
places like baja where people that cross
the border regularly get extra verified
by the u.s
and
cartel is aware of this so they see oh
you're a century pass guy
let me put some load on the bottom of
your car because you're already trusted
traveler and that's an easy way to get
drugs into the country it's like the
thing that kids do when you're like
shopping at a 7-eleven and then your
friend puts a candy bar in your hood so
you don't know what's happening and you
walk just like normally out of the store
and you're not acting suspicious and the
kid walks up and it's like yeah yeah
that only with the you know kia coke
you know that that happens a lot on the
border basically kilogram of coca-cola
yeah just a two-liter i guess right yeah
some booger sugar uh it's it's a
it's a classic story a lot of people get
caught like that and it's
again these guys are just
looking for holes in the already whole
written
wall
um so trump was right
he was right about what the securing the
border in general i mean securing the
border
specifically you uh so what you're
saying is trump is correct and we should
build a big beautiful 30-foot concrete
wall from sea to shining sea i mean i
think a wall is not feasible
i'm kidding
but i mean like in terms of like
focusing on the borders and we've got
serious problems here yeah so there's
serious problems with things coming from
the us into mexico that's part of the
issue it's not just things coming out
what's happening the other way
bullets guns right
to be fair obama gave those people those
guns so that was a that was a fair deal
that's the fast and furious
program it was bad that's like cia
delivering weapons to i mean i don't
know i don't know a lot about the fast
and furious on the u.s side i just know
it was a program started by the bush
administration specifically and then
continuing on with the obama
administration
uh two of my friends were killed by some
of those guns wow fn57 pistols one of
them was coming out of his house
with his daughter in the back seat and
his wife
he him and his wife got killed and the
daughter lost her arm um
the kids that shot them
um had five seven pistols uh 18 and 19
year olds you worked for you you were
working border security for mexico
though i was i was not working for
security i was working generalized
regional security basically but a lot of
our work was basically working against
people that were trying to get stuff
through the border we're trying to get
things from the us into how does that
work with the cartels then right because
the government's certainly not in
complete control
no uh i mean
there's there's fees there's really
realistically there's no border security
in in mexico there's there's a there's a
place where people cross by and there's
border agents but they're looking for
taxable goods they're not looking for
every now and then they'll get
contraband people trying to smuggle guns
or bullets in
uh but they're really realistically not
looking to secure the border on the
mexican side
and the government itself has a case of
amnesia every six years when the new
president comes in everything gets you
know all this that was successful this
was failure everything's bad get rid of
all of it i'm gonna start this new thing
and they just change the name of the
police change the uniform and same
corrupt people
yeah they're right on yeah
that why give up it's cash yeah all
their pockets are getting greased right
that's the thing and it's i mean i went
through
two uh terms of that basically doing 12
years working down there
it's unwinnable
do you think there's any value to the us
and of mexico and the us of america to
become one country
the whole concept of an american a north
american union
well i mean i think the us needs to
realize i mean that here a lot of people
just close the border you know just pull
the wall close the border that's the
second largest trade partner right
we we could however if we annex canada
and mexico can script the canadians to
fight the cartel's fault yes sure
just send them down there put down the
infant
you know that's probably
well it's another funny thing when the
uh when trump was in the presidency and
then the the border was you know a bit
harder to get across
um
cartel uh
people smugglers would just fly people
to canada
oh really yeah that was like a that was
one of the ways they would just fly but
canada and they just walked down you
know clever
there there are places in canada where
you can see these videos on reddit where
it's like they'll be like a teenager
standing in between the u.s canadian
border and it's just like a it's like a
a chain link you know like like a chain
going across like two orange posts
and there's no one anywhere near it
there's one part where i think it's in
minnesota
where it's the honor system you drive in
pull up to a booth go up to the booth
like it's like a little shack you go
inside pick up the phone and say hi you
give me your name and say i'm entering
the country and say okay thank you and
then you hang up and then you that's
beautiful yeah
that will never happen i think on the
southern border but it's an interesting
thing i mean it feels like it's worse
well people just walking through like
they don't even have the phone calls
they don't have a phone call i mean
there's
there's videos uh there's trail videos
and and rancher videos and taxes of just
guys and with a case on their backs and
dressed in like uh gamo and stuff like
that from cartel groups basically armed
cartel groups
in texas just you know moving around and
just coming back
what if like what if somebody has
property
up against the border and then they see
some dude with like an ak coming from
the border crossing onto their property
i mean do they have a right to defend
their property and stop the skies like i
mean i think they do have a right to
defend their property and they have the
means if they're in texas the problem is
that these people can get to you yeah
these people have a reach
and and their reach isn't dependent on
them crossing the border
uh another weird myth that mex that
americans have is that ah we don't want
they're coming into this country they
want the cartels here they're coming
they have been here for years
yeah they have they have
uh blood ties into in this country
they're in the military they're in the
military they're in the border patrol
they're in uh they're in politics
apparently you know they're out there
everywhere um
and uh you you you this
this border this border the border fence
and the board itself they crossed it
years back and it's a place like chicago
places like la
when they legalized weed uh some of
these groups had already gone into the
you know
they were already producing heat right
so
they went into the illegal weed and
illegal weed industry they did both they
were growing illegal weed in federal
lands on the u.s side wow so
that
they they are here like a lot i hear a
lot of people talking about military
intervention in mexico
it's not afghanistan it's not iran it's
not iraq
it's right there and also it's right
here
it's it's it's an it's if if that
happens
it's an interesting
it's going to be an interesting conflict
because
i don't think it's going to be like any
conflict this country has ever fought
specifically it's going to be really
close i mean they have they have
presence
scary um
and also the fact that uh you know
mexico has a lot of problems but it also
has a lot of resources right yeah
including the
one of the largest mineable lithium
deposits on the planet really
yeah are they mining it
and there was a splash water on it well
there was a there was a there was a
canadian company owned by china that
wanted to buy some of those mining
rights and that ended pretty quickly and
then right around the area where that
some of this stuff is is where the
mormon massacre happened down there
which is an interesting coincidence when
was that
ah that was about two years ago yeah
recent
um so which is crazy because isn't that
a star trek episode
what what that like mormons from earth
go find another planet and then like an
alien race kills them and there's an
incident where they go and investigate
them as mormon masters are we talking
about next generation next generation
yeah i've been thinking about that show
today i was into that when i was a kid
i'm sorry so you're getting
riker and i would get some of the uh
data arms you know just crush people
okay
okay
i'm confirming we were talking about the
lithium mining sonora largest deposit
with uh proven improvable reserves
reserves of 243.8 million tons of
probable reserves about four and a half
million tons of lithium as of 2019. if
the u.s actually goes in there into
mexico i think it's not going to be
about regime change or cartels or
terrorism it's going to be about making
batteries yeah
you guys ever put water on lithium no i
think i've seen it happen explodes right
yeah the uh it rips the hydrogen out of
the water i guess or or the oxygen out i
can't remember
and then it heats up really really
quickly and starts on fire that's the
craziest thing splashing water is that's
on fire yeah but this is like great
high school science class stuff so you
know yeah every now and then you'll see
somebody with a smartphone with a old
battery
boom boom so when you were doing
security you're out on the border and
you you're spending a lot of time out in
the middle of nowhere in the desert and
stuff yeah sometimes yeah you're seeing
aliens
i saw a few us drones flying places
where they shouldn't be flying i was
only i was only having what i want to
say is like have you experienced like
weird things
creepy things
yeah i assume the answer is yes right
but i don't i don't i don't want to make
this like obviously like bigfoot or
chupacabra no i mean like literally like
have there been like weird people have
you like seen operations happening uh
and weird stuff like aliens um
weird calls from high up people you know
um telling us to you know deliver
certain people that shouldn't be
arrested you know
um
uh corruption
corruption of some sort but on both
sides because or undercover operations
could be yeah who knows
seeing uh seeing armed americans in
mexico working and whoa yeah aren't
mexican americans working in mexico
armed that's a thing i've heard stories
that uh there was one story i was
reading about i don't know if you read
this one like a journalist went to el
chapo's house or whatever
you ever hear this one i think this this
may have been advice it's been a long
time but apparently like
uh
maybe maybe this is top maybe this is
confidential information i can't
remember anyway but he was working with
americans his security were all north
american accent guys like top level
former military stuff like that
the new generation cartel has a training
camp somewhere in in jalisco
and
american sf
something or other
has trained them so i don't know if it's
an official
it can't be an official capacity but
some sort of former military specialized
training that's what you see out there
has there ever been a moment where you
were like
crap your pants scared seeing something
uh geiger counter being put into a drug
tunnel
yeah what was up with that and it went
off like crazy or what no but just the
fact that they were testing the geiger
counter on on drug tunnels was weird you
know i was like uh like i knew what a
geiger counter was
and i was like wait
like is this some jack bauer
[ __ ] going on smuggling
who was putting the geiger counter in
there we just heard it so usually when
you would find something like that you
would get somebody on the u.s side
coming down into it to verify where it
you know verify the the exit point or
sometimes on the mexican side would go
down into it like hey we found something
we're going to walk
and then we're going to ping you to see
where it leads you know the military
would usually do that
but experiencing some of that and
actually seeing somebody we heard the
guy here counter was like
should we
not be here that was like a weird
unknown thing i mean i guess the worry
by the us government somebody might kind
of put a nuke into the country like that
i don't know like experience that once
and that was kind of like like creepy
how is it that there are all these
tunnels that they know about and they're
still there that they haven't like
buried them uh like who knows about them
well you just said there were like 80 or
some that we know about
people talk about somewhere along the
lines of 50 to 60 active tunnels on the
border and if they know i mean they know
they're somewhere they just don't know
how to find them or they know how to
find them but they won't do anything to
find them maybe
what if we did a moat and filled it with
alligators okay i read once in the news
that donald trump suggested that
alligator mode yeah i think it's going
to be expensive feeding all those
allegations alligators no also mexicans
have a tendency to make stuff out of
alligators
hunting grounds i can't do that there
was there was a story where they claimed
that trump suggested building an
alligator moat yeah it's that's insane
was that no
they just make stuff up yeah i mean
trump could nudge not just a joke and be
like you know we needed some alligators
in the mode right i'm just kidding and
they'd be like he said that's
true um
it's it's i mean it's a complicated
issue um
there's no way you can make that the
from cedar china and see a border wall
yeah i mean
some of the new parts of the board have
already border wall have already fallen
over you know this is the funny thing
about when trump was like when he wanted
concrete the the border patrol agents
were like we need to see on the other
side yeah we need to be able to see
what's coming yeah and he was like oh
okay and so then they experimented with
like half ballard fencing half concrete
and they're like you still can't see a
lot of it and then it doesn't make sense
and so they were like just do a big
multi-layered fence with patrols and
that seems to work and target key areas
and that seems to work
there's a lot of areas that's really
hard to pass anyway right like mountain
rocks and water yeah and also i mean
what you want if you're a smuggler is to
jump over a fence and have a population
where you can blend into immediately
that's what you want
um
another reason why you wouldn't have a
concrete border wall or just a flat
steel fence like that is because wind
knocks it over that's the simple right
reason why that's just not feasible um
but even with these uh new iron slats
that they made i mean there's a bunch of
cartel videos and just smuggling videos
of them
actually making their own fake fence and
putting it over the real one and putting
a hinge to open it up
or or small concealed doors where they
just pierce through so they'll cut it
and then replace it with a door the door
the door wow wow man
jump over it uh rope ladders
uh you name it they they do it it's it's
it's it's interesting to see then again
they say it's to slow people down
we we were talking before about you're
doing trainings on occult stuff yeah so
there's actually a position in which
they're like you need to explain to
these agents
occult ideology or like symbolism or
there's a law enforcement every now and
then reaches out i mean agencies local
state and federal sometimes reach out
with questions and and i do a lot of
consultation
related to them finding a safe house
somewhere and
i don't know like
i can talk about some of these but you
know somewhere on the east coast they
found this house with a bunch of
cartel stuff in it
um
guns plate armor
uh with a certain type of setup and a
giant santa muerte statue
santa marta is basically uh
it's a
in mexico they they venerate death
as a as a deity so
a giant
reaper statue in a place and it had
certain colors the candles were a
certain way there was a plate with
certain offerings
and uh you know five federal agents that
are caucasian from you know that have no
idea what they're looking at are now
asking me like what does this mean
and i was exposed to a lot of this stuff
growing up in mexico and also you know
being part of some of that growing and
going through my training and then
arresting people that are part of the
cult and also just going doing my
research out there
um so they asked questions like what do
these candles mean
or what does it mean if it's this color
or the the the statue was a black statue
it wasn't sometimes you find them in
rainbow colors or red or yellow rainbow
death rainbow death basically if you
want to cover all your your bases
lgbt death festival well it's not for
real like well i mean
if you have money problems love problems
if you want to kill somebody and you
don't want to get killed back
and you want uh to have
luck in a future endeavor you go for a
rainbow statue because it covers all
your bases yeah really yeah but if you
want to you know if you're in the
profession of death dealing in which
some of these people are basically
consider themselves agents of death
you have a black statue because she
gives you the authority to kill other
people and she you're under her
protection so
small insights like that is what i
provide to some law enforcement
professionals out there that are finding
some of these things i don't know what
they mean yeah do you think that they're
using them just to scare other people or
that they really believe i mean i know
it's speculation it's a belief it's a
belief and it's not just the cartels i
mean it's in the i mean i was exposed to
something in the police forces hazing
hazing rituals and it's like some other
people that i used to work with were
part of the cult as well
it's like it's like spread out
it's a desperate place it's one of the
most catholic countries in the world and
some of these things just thrive in
places like that
they have santa muerte which is a death
deity
they have uh malverde which is like a
mexican robin hood the dude that
used to rob the rich and would give the
money to the poor
he was hanged and they didn't allow him
to bury his body
but where his body eventually brought it
away and landed they put a bunch of
rocks there and they started venerating
him as a saint and you know there's a
there's a there's a shrine to him in
sinaloa
you go there and you see pictures of
people with their you know new raptors
in the states you know
like thank you for letting me cross and
i just came back to repay you you know
what you did for me or somebody with a
gold ak somewhere you know like this you
know wow so people it's a belief system
so a lot of this is actually being
brought with people stateside so there's
like a santa marta church in l.a
there's a roadside every now and then
you find like i i find like roadside
graffiti and or shrines of tim alberta
or like some of these things are like
it's here again now
does that just mean saint death santa
morte yeah so the holy death holy death
uh santa
was the saint of death basically have
you ever encountered some of these
people like in your deals with security
yeah do they come off as like weird when
you're encountering them i mean they
they are
realistically they're as weird as the
catholic
because it's it's basically uh
it's a concealed it's a it's concealed
within catholicism
but it's basically a cult or a
veneration of an aztec death deity
that's what it is it's a fusion it is
this last surviving lineage of any sort
of uh mexica or aztec death worship
in mexico so so you're bringing in the
sainthood of catholicism and you're the
same so so catholicism is basically the
cloak that it has concealed itself into
all day right so back in the day it
wasn't a public thing
so you would see a virgin mary statue
and behind her there was a skeleton
painted
so that's how they would hide their
veneration right and even to this day
the la virgen de guadalupe the version
the the brown version that they venerate
in mexico
there's an eagle
feathered cherub underneath her
pushing her up interesting and a cherub
doesn't have eagle wings
specifically black tipped eagle wings
that is the aztec war god
and the athletic morgon was given birth
to by quatrique
which
later on turned into holy death
so in a lot of ways it's always been
kind of concealed in plain view for
people but now it's adopted itself into
being venerated by marginalized
communities criminal groups police
officers the military you know that is
who venerates it
and its elements have crossed the border
and every now and then the law
enforcement finds them up here and
they're like what the hell are we
looking at you know
and uh you know some of the ritualized
killings they did they do it for for
video purposes that they spread on
social media stuff like that see that's
a bit different from like christians you
know
i don't i don't think we get a lot of
that yeah you get some weird stuff for
sure but alex jones was on before and
talking about like these these kind of
blood rituals that they would do the
aztecs and stuff and i looked into it
and it's called bloodletting it's an
ancient very well-known bloodletting is
just like a headache so you drain blood
or something similar yeah and it's like
he was like you put glass through your
genitals yeah that's all bloodletting
that's ancient
i went through a bunch of weird hazing
rituals coming up through training and a
lot of them were done by people so a lot
of the training that i went through
first was done by
gotham members
gotham members are the people that later
on turn into the zetas which is
basically a
mexican army sf group that
said well these guys pay more so they
just left these persons they just left
the barracks and became bodyguards to
one of the biggest cartel heads in back
then
a lot of these people a lot of these
guys were the ones that were in charge
of our training like coming up so they
were pretty brutal in some of the
training and they also introduced a few
weird occult elements into some of the
training we got right interesting
so
there was a they would cut you
to see if you would flinch right so like
uh
now that they cut me with a knife right
there
and there was always you know some sort
of pain or
just suffering or some sort to see if
you were strong enough and there was
always bleeding happening it was a weird
thing so you were under were you
undercover no this is this is this is
from this government training to get you
into go to work on on some of these
things uh and again it's a
the occultist elements in that are
everywhere like they're infused into the
culture you see them within the military
you see them with the criminal groups
you know um i remember the first time we
went to a house and we found this giant
actual human skull
statue
in the bottom of it it had a bowl and it
had the picture of the guy that ran us
or the got one of our bosses was in the
bowl and looked at us like took a
picture of it and sent it back
and he's like burn the
house um
you ever you ever experienced anything
in like pursuit of or investigation of
you know some occult stuff that gave you
pause or made you question
i mean is stuff real i think uh
things have a power that we give them
right things have a power the power that
we give them to uh so
specifically i think uh
there was there was this lady who was a
she was pretty famous i can't i can't
say her name but she was pretty famous
for being like the head witch of of
cartel people oh wow
and
[Music]
everybody feared her
everybody feared her she was he had the
male power and she will she could curse
you by your sight and stuff like that
when i wanted to learn more about this
type of stuff for my own research and
just to know about it to kind of gather
some of this information so then kind of
transfer to people that might need it
later on in life
um i helped out two of her sons that
were in a stolen vehicle thing right so
i helped him out
and i told him i just need an intro to
your mom so i can you know talk about
some of these things sure
i went to a place where she would do her
you know her work
she's arrived in a mercedes in the back
you know
changed the chains out of her you know
you know
good clothes and put on a weird you know
you know witch costume i guess
lady comes in my husband is cursed and
she he works for the cartels and he's
cursed and i need my work done on him
okay um i don't know the name of the
demon that is placed on your husband so
i can't take this job slides over the
500 she just put on the table it's like
wow this is an honest wedge
yeah wow
but if things start happening at your
husband's house at three in the morning
i think i might know the name so come
back
as soon as she leaves two kids walk in
with a bag full of cats
and they get tasked with going and
following this lady and going to her
house and dumping these cats in her
backyard
okay she comes back with five thousand
dollars
to get rid of this curse whatever this
is
um
i mean
black magic got its core is just a form
of weaponized psychology i think so this
is not something that made you believe
something made you this is something to
leave this is something that made me
respect the ability of manipulation that
some human beings have and reanalyze
everything i thought was real that's
classic con game material i knew a guy
once and he he he worked with the guy
and uh
when i started talking to him he told me
the story about how he lent his friend
five grand and i was like what whining i
said no it's fine he's good for it he's
put me back before and i'm like
dude what happened and he's like yeah he
has to borrow 500 bucks you know a
couple weeks ago and said i'll pay you
back on payday and i lent him the money
and then sure enough payday comes around
he paid me back no problem and then you
know he needed uh to help out
you know he was trying to get married
but his family didn't approve of his
wife so he needed you know to go fly
back home to china where he could then
you know sort things out with his family
and he he's got a job here i was like
bro you just got kant he stole all your
money he's never coming back
and that's that's what they do
you give me 500 bucks i wait a week hand
it right back to you i never spent it
that way in a week i can be like hey can
you lend me f you know five grand you're
like you know i'll pay you back i paid
you back last time that's the trick so
when she's like no no i can't take your
money because i have to know if the
demon is real
and then they go nuts on you and then
you're like she was right
yeah something happened it's it's a
it's a it's like i call it i nicknamed
mexico the upside down you know like
when i live here
because it's a different place people
don't realize how different it is
[Music]
we would get numbers attached to us as
like a call sign right or a nickname my
nickname was escalator you know they
called me skeletons pretty skinny when i
first got a shirt you got like a little
skeleton yeah there you go
and i had a number given to me at 2 4
and i had an upside down 4 on my number
and i didn't realize it was a joke
the joke was my first job working was to
cut people down from a bridge that were
hung by cartels that was one of my first
jobs
and talking about some hair-raising
experiences
this was pretty subtle
but it was it made me realize a few
things about mexico
um
we got to this place and they had uh
two or three
well two and what was remaining of
another one hanging from a bridge
we got there and i got i remember going
there and i got like hey bring the
breaching kit and which is a pair of
bolt cutters and a thing to knock down
the doors and i was like yeah we're
going to hit a house and they're in the
house and we're going to go somewhere
else oh and i got handed the boat
cutters and i didn't know what was going
to do when i got there i was like oh
we're going to you know you're the one
in charge of cutting them down
i i go over they put a flat back thing
on the bottom and we just cut somebody
down
and i was like that's a that's a [ __ ]
this is horrible
this is horrible older guy there smoking
a guy
jaramillo was his name
older guy smoking says
that's kind
they're being kind
like how is this kind
i mean at least there his family is
going to have a body to cry over and
bury
the body is a gift
and i was like brutal this is this is
this is kindness here that's why i've
heard crazy stories about what they do
to people like flaying them alive
playing along with
explosives putting on people
dragging them through a city
horrible i mean the videos are out there
and some of these i mean some of the
afters of these some things like um
there was a guy posolera was a stool
maker in tijuana as uh he never killed
anybody but he said that he learned from
israeli specialists how to get rid of
bodies and he got rid of bodies at an
industrial level
with caustic soda oh wow
and
uh like
one of my guys ran through a field once
and got off his foot inside of one of
the pits where he would dump things and
he got you had to go to the hospital for
chemical
stuff and also
the hole exposed the smell
which is to this day i can you know i
can't go to korean barbecue places
because it just freaks me out
people people in the united states don't
do not realize how good they have it
they they don't they don't they don't
not only realize how good they have it
up here they don't realize how some of
this is also starting to pop up up here
yeah
and also and also how some of this stuff
affects some of the stuff that happens
on their effects up here directly you
were saying before the show when we were
talking that like 90 of murders are
unsolved in mexico over 90 percent yeah
so i mean
it's it's a imagine that i read this
crazy story for our um more attentive
listeners you made for me say it i think
i was reading on like read it this young
woman was at a bar i think it was in
austin or whatever and she was with her
boyfriend and like two of his friends so
it's like three guys in a chick
they walk out of the bar and she's like
10 or 15 feet behind him just like
whatever
and then as they're goofing off and
walking
her being that far apart was enough car
pulls up they jump out and grab her and
try pulling her into the car
she screams her boyfriend the friend's
here and they run over and they grab her
they're trying to keep her out of the
car and the car starts driving and they
pull her out and the car speeds off and
apparently that's like these kidnappings
in texas and places like that on the
border you think you're in this american
city everything's going to be great and
then a car just pulls up and the next
thing you know you're a slave
i'll i'll give you this story and you
tell me where it happened a bunch of
armed cartel members dressed like
federal agents go to a house do a mock
raid on the house abduct somebody and
then they found him later on dead where
does this happen kansas city that's
california oh let's go see california
for sure this is california where in
california
uh right across the border um
san diego county yeah uh which which
one's on the us at mexicali or calexico
uh calexico and then mexicali is just in
the other central
yeah um arizona is the abduction capital
of the u.s wow arizona arizona um a lot
of abductions happen in migrant
communities that never get reported a
lot of executions and murders happen in
migrant communities i never get it that
makes me wonder when you said 90 or more
percent of murders are unsolved is that
accounting for people that just
disappear no that's not accounting for
people that just disappear which i don't
i don't have the numbers in my head
right now but they're pretty
astronomical as far as how many people
are just missing in mexico which
basically means dead which basically
they could be sold in slavery yeah well
that's an interesting other aspect of it
like um
during the cobalt epidemic uh
you know uh protozoals were stocked
which it means in certain parts of the
country
child labor is
allowed
in the states only in the you know when
it comes to agriculture
there's kids working in some of these
fields government governor newsom in
california and california has a winery
that didn't close during cobalt and
there was a bunch of kids working on
those fields that are you know mexican
immigrants
they are working to pay off their
crossing a lot of these people
so when a lot of ways there's
modern-day labor yeah going on right now
um getting across the cross through the
border not like these the the haitian
push came in but like if you're a
mexican and you cross the border
illegally
you have to pay
and if you can't pay you get
you get a
little tab on your wrist so when you get
picked up on the u.s side they know
you're still low so you get processed in
a bit different way
and some of these people end up on in
field
in inter manufacturing places across the
the country and some of them go into if
they're female some of them go into
the trade as well
and they're they're basically working
off their debt and if they can't pay it
their families that are already set up
stateside are paying
wow so
what's like the average that someone
would have to pay for something like
that it depends on who you are and when
you're crossing the 5 000 is a number
that i've heard where do people get this
money
they
they they don't get it so they cross and
they pay it off over years sometimes and
some people might owe five thousand
dollars but you think they're going to
say oh with interest now so of course
and these people get stuck into this
circle and also
if they don't pay and they get you know
they get something bad happen to them do
you think they're going to report that
to the police you're in the united
states
it's a whole silent community that just
doesn't say anything perfectly down man
yeah i was just thinking like geez start
a gofundme to help pay these people off
but i'm like can you even get involved
in that because it's already this
illegal trade you can't pay them
it just would make the system worse it
would incentivize more of the same
how do we fix this
uh we recognize i mean first recognition
of
of
a
narco insurgency with multiple fronts
right next door to your country and it
is a narco insurgency
recognize that the fact that the mexican
government is not going to help you fix
the problem you know because it's part
of the problem
uh realize that they are terrorist
organizations they are their their own
definition of a terrorism you should the
u.s should come up with a new definition
for them because they are a new
definition uh they're utilizing pipe
bombs mortar bombs they're utilizing ira
style tactics to develop explosives now
on drones that they land on police
vehicles
um
they're in that game watch dogs you'll
play that mm-hmm yeah they can do drones
with bombs on them and then you can or
you can go to michoacan you can see it
for real
man i remember warning some uh some
government officials when i was doing
consulting on drone stuff when drones
started first like consumer level drones
were first becoming uh prominent
actually uh they there was
this organization that sent a
person to like these news organizations
and they asked me because i had a bunch
of expertise in doing work with drones
and then i was talking to them and they
were like what are the concerns about
safety and i was like oh the most
obvious one someone straps a bomb to a
consumer-grade drone for a couple
hundred bucks and there's nothing you
can do about it
and they were like
yeah like what do you do
even if you get the drone down it's a
flying bomb it's a flying bomb so the
cartels are basically making homemade
claymore mines that are putting and
they're putting them on the bottom of a
drone and these drones are dirt cheap
yeah they're they're and all these
chinese alibaba level drones you know
but they're they work they're workable
and you have one of those go off high
enough that the radius is pretty good to
get a lot of people or they land on top
of a car and explode them especially
they put like nails and stuff
yeah uh something how much weight they
can carry on them if they do a you know
moderate sized drone they can
there's just crazy stuff i posted a
video up recently of a quad drone with a
guy holding on to it whoa and they were
being lifted up and it was like
somewhere in the hills in mexico they're
kind of testing that out for something
maybe wow breaking somebody out of
prison
casey neistat did that big drone where i
pulled him on a snowboard and then like
lifting him up and everything too yeah
that's exciting i mean i know it's a
different context but that's super cool
i mean if
chapa was was in prison long enough i
mean he probably could have gone out
with a drone that would be some batman
level villainy going on yeah i mean it's
the craziest thing right now a drone big
enough can just automatically fly by
tracking gps and then stop over you and
then drop a rope and you can it can pull
you out yeah yeah that's crazy i mean i
i was i remember finding one of the
first drones like like a first drug load
drones in tijuana and i'd never seen
one outside like in reality i saw them
on on the internet and stuff like that
and all of a sudden i find this
quadrone on the ground with a giant
brick of meth you know wow and how big
was a drone uh it's about i mean
it's probably about that big those guys
when they fly their blades are strong
and so fast they'd slice your fingers oh
wow yeah no joke when we found it we
still had one of the guys had still had
his sirens on of the police car he was
driving he said shut him off
and we can that was one of several like
you could hear the
so that one had gone down but there are
others still up there yeah
and this is this is a while ago this is
that 2008 or something like that 2008.
yeah
wow and this is they're they're
they're they're better now at it yeah
um
according to most of those guys they say
magic hour is
moonless night with fog
that defeats every single uh security
feature of the border right now a
moonless light with fog that that'll
that'll get its magic hour for them zero
visibility and you can't
you can't yeah you can't send a
helicopter out there and
yeah i think they're i think like
infrared ir you know detection but i
mean i would imagine they don't have all
the advanced technology all over i mean
right now they don't have enough people
to i mean
again it's magic hour for them like
everybody is you know on the border well
they were on the border trying to quell
this
massive migration push into the into the
united states
i mean other parts of the border were
probably ignored and were left alone and
just i mean again it was magic
hour you know what got through
a lot probably you know
so there's there's no end to this i mean
i i wonder if the stuff we see in the
news
actually let me ask this does it feel
like it's worse now than it's been in
the past
yes
i think it's uh it's uh just numbers
wise it's worse um i
having experience like i went through
the group that i was a part of
pacified the most dangerous city on the
planet at that point which was tijuana
and it got off the most dangerous list
things went back to
normal
economic boom a bunch of sky
high rises came up in tijuana and it's
currently going through that
and now it's back at number it's back at
almost number one again right
and you like you're like scratch your
head like we did all this work like what
happened to all this work
and then you start realizing that you
know well the politics went to the left
on this side
um
we were put through a process of
selection and also uh review so i had to
do a polygraph exam every year and my
financial look for looked through with a
you know with a fine tooth comb i went
through an fbi background check
i had random drug testing psychological
evaluations and this was tedious they
would they would go to our houses and
take pictures of how many tv screens we
had there and if we had a new one you'd
have to ask
that ended
because people started saying it was
inhumane and it was against their human
rights so
when i
the last day i was on the job
there was a guy in that the new guy that
was in charge
which we investigated for cartel ties
was there at the office and i was like
wow weren't you like not here oh i'm
back and all my back paid my back back
paid everything he's back and now he's
in charge
yeah it sounds like they sold you out it
i mean they sold everybody out and
another thing about it is like i'm not a
i'm not specialty guy i know a lot of
things i trained a lot of people and i
had a lot of weird training from the u.s
side and the mexican side
all the people that i used to work with
which were also trained like me that
speak the same level of english that i
have that have the same training same
education same experience
those people didn't have the
opportunities that i had
what do you think they're working now
why are they working
twelve thousand dollars every two weeks
and they're working for one of the most
largest cartel groups on the planet
right so so they were like basically
every year they were testing and
checking and checking to see if you'd
been co-opted and then who decided like
what president or who what organization
decided to stop the last president was
uh
the last president went through a
process of kind of changing some of
those things again mexico has six years
of a presidency and then it just goes
into a process of amnesia or everything
that the last president did if it was
good it's bad
and we went from the far right down
there which which was felipe calderon
which started the drug war
to a president now that invited the
venezuelan military to march on mexican
independence day and chow viva maduro
aviva
so that's we're going through right now
and most of the people that i used to
work with i mean they clearly were like
this is yes let's just go to work for
the bad guys or
the good guys depending on where you're
down uh right where you are down there
you can see what this this like leftist
maduro stuff manifests into i mean this
this guy went to the poppy fields and
said what about our drugs yeah this is
it's a they're they're normalizing a
bunch of stuff that is it's not normal
you know well it's it's it's gonna it's
a fire it's a fire that's spreading it's
a fire it was what's left over after the
fire burns down the forest burnt husks
and also i mean when i say normalizing
things i mean
when he leaves office
things are normal the president going to
sinaloa and talking about supporting
poppy field
plantations and
and uh shaking hands with uh the known
like
chapa guzman's mom and the lawyer and um
naming the former governor of sinaloa
the ambassador to spain which is the
the door of drugs into into europe wow
but it just does it because it's fine
because he's the president and it's okay
and it's fine and the the
the um
just the the behavior and the the people
that are being invited in and
the open relationship to cuba now and
cuban intelligence being all over the
country now it's kind of weird
i want to pull up the story real quick
um
this is from the bbc biden said quote
people will pay for horseback charge on
migrants at border so i'm sure you heard
the fake news
that the guy the border patrol guys were
riding the horses and the photos came
out and the left democrats were like
they're whips right so then what
happened is the binding administration's
like okay you can't use horses anymore
and now biden is saying they're going to
pay the reason i bring this up is you're
just talking about how
you know once once the left came in all
of a sudden they were much more in favor
or at least yeah you know it's like
so the the current president down there
said
hugs not bullets that was his whole
counter
that's that was his whole security
policy for the cartels so whether what
you know for for the us whether it's
intentional or not you have joe biden
now based on fake news condemning the
border patrol guys
it's just continually weakening our
security
it's erasing it just knowing some of the
people that were there because i i know
some of those people that were there a
lot of them were latinos a lot of them
were actually mexican uh second
generation third generation mexican
people uh they're riding around in
horses and they're utilizing the strap
have you ever ridden a horse they're not
they don't have crops of whip they don't
have a weapon rain the rains that's what
you see
they are completely undermanned under
supported and they're trying to do a job
which is stopping people from crossing
the border illegally and also
i mean there i saw
somebody go out down there trying to
make it about race um of course and uh
just seeing so the u.s and again this
this from my experience training law
enforcement here stateside
just went through the whole black lives
matter
corrosion
which is a corrosion speaking of
somebody comes from a country where
police are not viewed well
this leads down a very dark path yeah
people don't want to be police officers
in the united states anymore
police academies have whole generations
that are just empty um there's places
where they don't have police you know
they can't pay them enough and or you
can't get paid enough to work in some of
these places
that leads to a void
an authority and policing void in some
places
um what comes next
you know
mexico comes next you know uh the
corrosion of uh
of uh of the small rules getting set to
the side small rules get set to the side
you know you can walk into a
you know a target in california and just
fill a bag full of stuff and just walk
out no problem as long as it doesn't
pass that's
you know small rules and i'm from
tijuana you know it's not
it's not it's not a it's not a first
world place
but i go to la and i want to wash my
wash my hands afterwards right it's
amazing to see how it's
slowly shifting the corrosion that's
come
in this country as far as being against
law enforcement again not all law
enforcement is okay there's a bad people
in law enforcement there's bad horrible
people not enforcing them in mexico
uh there's four there are people that
did horrible things here in the states
there's people that are corrupt that are
working for a law enforcement people
that shouldn't be working for law
enforcement here stateside that have a
completely bad mindset as part of what
they're doing
but what comes if you don't have a
police force
you know
like i was in port the i was in the
portland riots day 101 of the portland
riots i went out there oh wow people
feel like ahead are you going to be out
there yeah what do you want to do what
do you want to see i always want to go
to the weird places so i went to the
riots
percent cs gas was being utilized
against the protesters
which is basically pepper yeah and
something you put on your stake
there was a snack cart going through the
protest line which is pretty amazing
there was a little asian uh
girl with a bicycle helmet shouting you
know
kill the police or something like that
and then somebody threw a molotov
uh at the police and then landed on the
feet of a protester there who do you
think all of them screamed for when that
happened of course and the you know the
state police walked over put him out and
went back through the line you want to
know what would happen if there were no
police
i'll tell you
if something like portland happened
in a place where there were no police
the locals would walk out with their
guns and it would not be pretty see the
issue is in places like portland where
you do have the right to keep and bear
arms more so than many other states
regular people know
if antifa shows up with molotov
cocktails and i defend myself i go to
prison
so they don't do it it's because they're
scared of the police and the police
allow anti-for free reign yeah
so i'm not i've not been a big fan of
you know the police
over that specifically and over the
lockdown stuff and a lot of people have
said oh you can't blame the cops gotta
blame the leadership and i'm like no i
think if the cop walked up to the guy
and arrested him and said you deal with
it later at the very least you know that
would slowly start putting a stop to
these things if they started actively
you know going where these rioters were
going when they go into residential
neighborhoods and stopping them from
going to people's homes and threatening
the residents how are you doing it
though i was there for a night and i i'm
not the you know the smartest you know
man alive or anything like that but i
was there for a night and i could figure
out that all these people there were not
from portland that they were all bust in
and or drove in and all
carpooled in i could tell you exactly
where they parked i could tell you where
their plates were from i could tell you
where they were car surfing i tell you
just by walking around there and hearing
their conversations i could tell you
what social media they were utilizing to
organize their endeavors and it was all
a show it was all a played out show look
at the mccloskeys
right you can criticize them for waving
the guns around or whatever but the
point is a a group of black lives matter
people
broke into private property
and when they simply brandish their
weapons on their own property as people
were on their property and said get out
they got arrested and charged for it
yeah so regular people know this antifa
gets free reign black lives matter gets
free reign you can't defend yourself
remove the police
people start defending themselves the
riots are over instantly people it would
not be it would not look good and i
would not want to see what happens but i
tell you if the cops won't actually
enforce this if the justice department
if the justice system
will not hold these people to account
eventually the police aren't losing
support we start seeing things like we
did where where trump supporters and
conservatives were throwing the blue
lives matter flag on the ground and
stomping on it yeah and then eventually
they're like i don't care get rid of the
cops whatever so be it if you're not
going to protect me you're going to
ignore what they do and then come at me
when i try to protect myself like we've
seen in the press numerous times
people are going to say no to it it's a
small one they're paying attention it's
the small rules that go first and then
the big ones start getting corroded and
i think we're past the small rules part
oh yeah it's it's it's insane and and
again i come from a country where that
happened probably in the 80s and the 90s
and this is the this is what comes after
you know mad max level
the fact and you see the haitian
migrants walking back and forth yeah
there's no border i'm sorry there's no
border you can't call it a border it's
not that's not correct it's it's not
there there's no border and also the
people that are enforcing the border on
this side are now even more neutered
that they were right so
you go into you know hypotheticals and
you know again if somebody like some
evil entity out there wanted to do
something on the border christmas right
now christmas
yeah this is christmas right now you
know uh
and also
who wants to go into border protection
you know that you know now like who
wants to go into any of these jobs
that guy with the reins he's getting
being demonized by the president they
took their horses away right or fake
news biden is attacking them saying
they'll pay because
people on the democrat this is what
happens every single time this is why
look the democrats come out and say
hunter biden's laptop stories fake news
when it was real they come out and they
say russia gate is real news when it's
fake ukraine gate is real news when it's
fake they say uh they're whipping people
it's fake news how often are we going to
see our culture our country capitulate
to the lies from these psychopaths who
just scream random garbage when they
panic
yeah i mean the racism thing with a with
one of the most latin groups of federal
police out there is pretty insane uh i
don't get me wrong i i'm a migrant like
i'm a legal resident of this country i
went through my my
my process
during trump's election which made my
process that usually takes six months
into one that took two years
and i'm not a fan and i was pretty
disappointed but i went through it
legally right i went through it legally
and
i'm an idiot
okay you just wait
and i'll say in spanish que pendejo you
know
i should have just you know just sat on
that borders crossed and get shipped out
to any you know whatever
i got i got i got friends
i have a friend in eastern europe and
it's actually a brutal conversation to
be like i would like my friend to simply
visit
simply visit you know two weeks come see
america for once damn near possible
and then she's like should i just go to
mexico
and i was like well i can't you know
obviously
you're joking yeah right
but that's the reality of like even
people in other countries are like
that's why you see people in africa fly
to brazil and then come to mexico
because they know the border it doesn't
exist it's an open joke internationally
that you know it's it's a hard thing to
get a visa but it's easy just travel to
mexico yeah and it's not you don't so
that you don't even need a visa to go to
mexico you can just violently cross the
southern border into mexico
be beat federal police in mexico beat
them up cross the border violently just
make it all the way through go to the
border and be welcomed on the other side
that they'll fight so they'll fight the
police and in the southern border
they'll fight the police in the southern
border they'll throw rocks at them
they'll
they'll be violent towards them uh
they will go through communities and all
the communities are just doing this to
them
you know just go back
the pro there was there were pro when
the first caravan cara migrant cameraman
came up into tijuana
the locals protested
i remember that they make tijuana great
again hats which i may or may not have
something to do with that
um
the the the the locals made were wearing
the the mayor of tijuana was wearing a
make tijuana great again right but
they were like called racist like all
these guys are brown right and also we
just absorbed a whole segment of the
population of the haitian migrants
coming into tijuana which they they're
i mean as far as the our experience with
them they were pretty good they they
melded into the populace they worked
they're flying now these uh hondurans
came in
and they were saying that they were
going to turn tijuana into honduras
right they were saying that they were
going to shoot people that they wanted
to mess with them you know two of them
got picked up by the cartels immediately
whoa
immediately so they calmed down a bit
and then they were complaining about the
food that they were being given
because
they didn't want beans
they thought that was pig food
which is if you tell that to a mexican
[Laughter]
but you that's the experience that the
locals have had with them and it's not a
good experience and it's amazing that
you know
the first the camp they had was next to
a school they had to call the school
down because they kept getting harassed
by the
by the people there
but the americans would come in
and hand out backpacks uh
tents food clothing
and these guys were like thank you
muchas gracias thank you thank you and
then you would see that at the open air
market being sold and flipped yeah right
and it was like
is anybody seeing this
american media shows up get the kids out
let's put them around and the females
out put them here on the outskirts so
they can get that's what they need that
way aoc can show up and start crying at
the fence tricking a bunch of dumb
people and devoting away their rights
and their and their sovereignty the last
the last caravan that showed up in
tijuana set up right on the border and
right in the middle of it and i'll post
this picture up tonight i think i'll
find it right in the middle of that camp
biden flag
yeah
you know and yeah i went around and
talked to a few of them they were pretty
defensive
but main thing is that
doors open welcome in this is the time
the door's going to close again probably
in a few years so we need to go now let
us in joe biden you said that in the 80s
um is when the little things started to
become overlooked and then it led slowly
led towards i mean mexico's have always
been
the corruption's always been systemic
there but
yeah i mean the true corrosion that uh
you know that you know criminal
enterprises and been feeding the massive
drug market in the states and the
corruption that kind of produced in
mexico kind of start
growing and
how the corruption seeped into
uncorruptable organizations like the
military mexico had like
the military was like the uncorruptable
like these are these are the last events
and then you had the zetas you know
and then you had a bunch of generals
being arrested for cartel ties and then
that shifted now that's why you see the
mexican marines being utilized more now
the u.s said well
we don't use the mexican military we're
going to use the mexican marines now
that's what we saw during the chapel
raid
but now some of those guys have been
arrested guarding cartel guys you know
bodyguarding cartel guys uh
mysterious stuff happening in um in
certain parts where they can they
control the ports i mean if they are
incorruptible
and they are the leading defense in
mexico against the cartels why are voice
fentanyl flooding the country these guys
are in control of ports so
it's all for money
i mean yeah for them yeah i think i
think a big part of his money
i think a big part of it is lack of
opportunity i mean for somebody like me
growing up in tijuana
either it was going into work for a call
center going to work for a cartel or
going to work for the government
and after coming out of working for the
government i can't tell you the
difference between working for a cartel
or a government down there as far as how
it it was at the end color centers are
rough that's boring i mean
that's that's the opportunity you have
down there wow right like i was in i was
studying medicine when 9 11 happened
and the economy just went in the toilet
down there after that because nobody
wanted to cross a border and have fun in
tijuana anymore
so
the only opportunity for me and a few of
my friends it's like when i grew up in
tijuana i was like a skater kid skated
the first time i did any lock picking
and stuff like that now i teach that and
stuff like that the first time i didn't
lock picking and stuff like i would
break into some
cartel house that had been abandoned and
we wanted to skate the pool
right so that was my childhood
and it was fun it was it was it was
interesting tijuana was a pretty
interesting place
about a change
a lot of my friends that i grew up with
went to work for the cartels
there was a redhead kid that i used to
that hates to know
you know i went in to work for the
government and he
we both used to skate you know
uh he always uh
his shorties was his thing you know you
know that's that was his brand that yeah
yeah yeah he had the matka shoes with a
zipper tongue thing that would hide his
weed in there
um
that he was a great kid you know
hung out with him
and we just lost touch when i turned 20
and i went to work for government he
just you know disappeared
i found him working later on
i was walking across a gas station or
doing some surveillance stuff
and he called me over like
wearing a
ak-47
magazine carrier and an ak in his hand
it's like hey what's up man it's like it
was uh come over he's like come over
here
so
i wasn't in a uniform i wasn't i was
carrying a gun i was working but i
wasn't doing anything specific as far as
being overtly what i was
called me over
gave me a hug like hey dudes like what
have you been doing oh just been [ __ ]
you know looking for work and stuff like
that
and he leaned over and said i know what
you do for a living
you probably better get out of here it's
like yeah dude i'm sorry man yeah what's
up with you i'm like i'm just working
here you should come over like it's a
good i mean it's well paying at you like
that i'm like oh wow dude
i walk out of there like phone's going
crazy because they saw me you know
and as soon as i got back to the group
that i was with the military showed up
and they
shoot out for i don't know like a solid
30 minutes whoa
i
i went there afterwards
and
it took me about 10 minutes to find him
he was
shot dead underneath the car
he was the only one with red hair there
she was he was a redhead
i stayed with his body and i stayed with
his body all night and called his
parents
to to to release the
body um
the war down there is different it's not
it's not going off to afghanistan and
doing things not going off to the middle
east it's it's it's within
our homes with people that we speak the
same language with
sometimes we would kill one of them and
they would kill one of us and the
funerary services were at the same place
geez
um it's a different war and as far as
what it produces as far as individuals
and people and
bad people and just the
the uh
the methodology that is being showcased
as far as the first people that i've
that we've seen in the western
hemisphere weaponize drones with cartels
and that's a that's a light that is now
like ideological and methodology
methodological
idea now that is out there
um
the first people that weaponize torture
videos and stuff like that on social
media where the cartel is not isis isis
got the idea from the cartels
um
it's it's turning into the the the uh
the school you know it's turning into a
school of thought of method
it's turning into a a producer of people
of bad people and good people maybe i
don't know but with people
that are capable you know
um
what you saw in afghanistan when the cia
cia went in there and trained some of
the some of the local populists to fight
the soviets and what that later turned
into
um the u.s trained people in mexico
that was one of them
and what is that going to turn into in a
few decades
you know same thing it always does yeah
that's it's it's the uh it's a scary
thing that i again i'll see this cover
on the u.s side a lot and people don't
talk about it that much or if they do
that's
it's like something that's in the future
for them like they're coming here
eventually they'll come here it's here
already
um you know that's that's that's that's
the scary part of it that just the
ignorance around it
you think if people learn spanish it
will help i think all of you are going
to be speaking espanol or mandarin in a
few years so those two yeah probably we
should be teaching kids like six or
seven languages in school
well yeah well you know we don't other
other countries do we don't yeah yeah
yeah
you could you can't get a uh you can't
get into a career path in mexico unless
you know uh english
and it's like that's true for a lot of
countries though yeah it's it's always
been interesting for me to like meet
people in the states that don't speak
another language it's pretty weird right
yeah that's most i'm pretty sure right
it's
a nice try
like i travel across the country every
weekend i do classes all over the
country so i get to see weird places and
experience
this country for three years i've been
traveling non-stop
so it's just interesting seeing going
from la to
alabama to
going to like living in kentucky for a
bit and everybody was like hey ed why
don't you worry about kentucky it's very
racist it's like
mexico's family
these people are just people are
amateurs
yeah america's like one of the least
racist places i've ever been to
you know maybe maybe it's it's hard to
quantify exactly how racist the country
might be
especially like you you go to some of
the scandinavian countries and they're
like arguably way more racist but some
people might be like kind of not but
i'll tell you this i think sweden is
super super super racist okay yeah
they're the kind of racists where they
really don't like non-swedish people
but they openly pretend like they're not
racist so they do a bunch of things to
make it
they want to make it seem like they're
not racist they're super welcoming but
then behind closed doors they're like
others are not yeah totally no legit
uh we have blackface comedy still on tv
in mexico oh wow wow uh there's a
there's a comic called
people can research this and you tell me
that's on the newsstand still so it's
uh there's there's uh all of the
telenovelas and all the news and all a
lot of the popular culture down there
everybody on tv is caucasian the mexican
caucasian people because that's
our idealized version of beauty you know
wow uh you give a kid a brown barbie and
a white barbie and ask the kid which one
is the evil one oh wow
no way
that's an experiment that they did down
there um
yeah
so well so what's the result i mean the
we'll raise the brown one and what do
you think what do you think if you did
that united states today to a kid which
one do you think they would raise up the
white one that's right that weird diablo
blanco how about just like i don't know
you can't tell if they're evil or not
well i mean that's like look at that
it's super hard yeah
and it's
as far as the racism thing i get a kick
out of seeing some of the commentary as
far as racism here in the united states
when i you know like go to asia you know
just see how different asian countries
eat each other go to mexico uh in my
like i'll tell this story about my
family can i tell this it's just a small
short story my daughter is on the light
side you know she's she's a bit
light-skinned
um my niece has a daughter and jesus
brown's eye
on christmas my dad put my niece's
daughter on his knee and my daughter on
the other knee she told my daughter
you're the princess of the family
and he says daughter says like what
about me you can be the princess's maid
wow that's my daddy that's my dad yikes
that's so i i i that that's that's
that's dad that's how that's how the
that's how the culture is down there
it's like i saw it i was like that's how
it is in brazil yeah so when i was down
in brazil uh i wouldn't i've been down
there several times actually have a visa
and what i was being told by our fixer
our local guy our friend he's like he's
like a pothead owned a headshot
he was like
they there are people who are both black
and he was he was like and they'll argue
with each other over who's black yeah
yeah yeah because like it's bad and
they're they're all extremely racist
even against themselves and he was like
it's crazy to see that people who are
darker skinned will like they'll pick a
grandmother
and then she'll be a picture of her with
her husband and their kids and it's like
having more and more white kids and then
their great their great granddaughter is
like white and she's like how proud am i
that's that's really weird to me how
racist these people are just just to get
it clear my dad is brown you know he's
not like you know
that it's just that's just how things
work outside of the united states you
know people these these college kids
they don't get it they're like america's
racists
dude come down not only that but i'm
like whenever i hear one of these people
say that america's racist i'm like have
you ever spent 10 minutes in a skate
park
in america
yo if you if if you if you're look you
want to go somewhere to hear the n-word
more than any go to a skate park i'm not
even kidding it's like you just it's
like every other word yeah because like
an urban culture thing now i guess for
these kids yeah uh that i i get my mind
gets blown when i see second generation
third generation mexican
you know kids here and they use the
n-word more than anything it was like
why are you using that word that's not a
you know again i'm new here so i don't
know yeah so i'm just hearing it i'm
like wow
let's go to soup culture let's go to
super chats everybody if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to the channel we we love hanging out on
friday nights we always try to just kind
of like chill lay back and make friday
nights just a little different
not so heavily focused on like the new
cycle of the week or whatever like we do
in the earlier earlier in the week it's
more chill and more chill so smash that
like button send me super chats we're
going to read some of your comments
right here all right let's see
jackson dowdle says can you have a
debate between an ancap and a populist
like brian kaplan and jack murphy
yes brian kaplan not familiar with who
brian kaplan is but you know we can
certainly organize something like that
that'd be fun
all right this question i'm assuming is
for uh ian duct tater says so did any of
the cults ever manage to summon cthulhu
is that what actually happened in 2020 i
defer to ed i mean i don't know
i i i gave a death whistle to joe rogan
that he blew and that everybody blames
cobit on that so i don't know no for
real yeah so like uh so in mexico they
have these uh death whistles it's an
aztec death whistle supposedly when the
aztecs would attack a village they would
blow those every night before they
attacked to just keep people up you know
yeah so it said then he blew it i said
that's pretty cool you want this like oh
yeah
he blew it on the show yeah
so wait joe rogan blew the death whistle
on his show yeah
proves it there's a few of them you know
so maybe that happened
i don't know i don't know
maybe some somebody else's version of
cthulhu you know yeah i guess i guess
the answer's no short answer all right
stephen valdez says ed is a legend ed
are you ever going to write a book
it's uh yeah yeah that's it's not what
people think i'm not uh
most of my writing is going to be
related to
post-traumatic stress
uh processing you were saying
psychedelics have helped uh some certain
certain certain types of psychological
have helped in the processing part of it
yeah um
it's it's uh
every now and then i write these things
called fever dreams and i post them up
on my instagram account and there they
seem to touch people uh it's
my my world has ended a few times in a
lot of ways and uh talking about some of
the drama stuff talking about some of
the i mean i'm nine months on the wagon
right now
so it was like how how many years were
you involved in this experience uh 12
years working and right now six years on
the road
teaching training and stuff like that so
it's it's been a road
before we before we move on i have to
ask you do you think that the reason
that some of these military members and
police officers use this symbol of santa
muerte is because it takes some of the
guilt of killing other people off of
them ah it is definitely uh
yes they have dispensation um
and so in a place where the government
doesn't really have your back and there
is no realistic
so like in the u.s you go off and fight
for your country and you get back and
sometimes you get flag waves on you you
get you know if you were in uniform you
fly
um you can fly for a discount or for
free and you get preferential treatment
if you're a veteran and stuff like that
there's no such thing in mexico you can
spit on oh what do you do like i did
what i did for a living for a long time
for my family
uh because it's something to be ashamed
of
so
uh
so there's no concept of a veteran in
mexico right
although it's it's clearly a giant war
that we just went that was currently
still going through right
so
if you don't have any support if you
don't have any that
i learned about post-traumatic stress
when i came to this country i didn't
know what that was you know that that's
the level of just
abandonment that people have down there
wow uh so
i think part of that is that you know
just seeking some sort of comfort or
some sort of backing and something that
is as dark and or as light as a death
deity
you know that's what i think that's a
big reason why some of that is so
popular and prevalent down there
interesting okay all right john doe says
it costs 2 500 for a u-haul from
maryland to florida but only 600 dollars
from for a u-haul from florida to
maryland they claim supply and demand
we'll see it's it's really simple
if you're in maryland there's probably
no trucks because everybody's fleeing
if you're in florida there's a ton of
trucks because nobody's leaving because
everybody's fleeing to florida so if you
want to go back it actually works out
really well for them because you're
basically doing them a service bringing
a truck back otherwise they got to go
pick the truck up and then bring them
back so yeah it costs more money how
about that
all right here's a good one jason bryan
says did dim fool talk about the arizona
audit yet
no we didn't why uh it just came out
so you know i often wondered to myself
i'm like there's a lot of people who
jump the gun on stories and then get
them wrong and i'm like this thing was
like announced i think like 4 p.m and
there's like no way i'd have enough time
to go through what they said to talk
about it on a show but
you know here's i'll tell you this
the other night a whole bunch of stories
emerge where they they said the arizona
audit confirms joe biden won okay
they didn't actually even see the audit
when they wrote those stories and that's
the important detail because i'm pretty
sure the audits don't
actually make any strong assertion like
that
what what there is something going
around it's showing a list of like um
failure rates basically like
duplicate votes or things like that so
there's a lot to go through i have not
fact checked any of it and by the time
we're going to do a show on a friday
night there's just
look i got to tell you guys the worst
possible day to release information that
this is on a friday like everyone's
tuned out view counts are always way
down honestly i don't get it and then
they give the media an opportunity to
preempt them on a thursday which is not
a good day but not a friday
it's better than a saturday i guess but
seriously a friday evening is when you
publish news to die yeah so uh i'll look
into it and i'm gonna go through all of
it absolutely and i got to tell you i
think it's a lot of what we heard from
matt brainard uh check out the members
only segments at timcast.com and then
we'll see what we can get to in those
when we break it down
all right montana linderman says today's
my birthday and i'm stuck at work but at
least i have tim and everyone to listen
to i watch you guys every night you guys
are amazing montana thank you for your
super chat and thanks for for watching
and listening to the show happy birthday
you know it's just uh we we
look at cameras and we talk about stuff
sam finley says ed calderon makes james
bond look like a punk
hold on
no
[Laughter]
all right let's see
trevor cameron says tim gonna play some
more d and d does the dm have a hard
time keeping track of initiative check
out my kickstarter and fb
deck of heroes and fiends october 1st
well alright then
yes we do plan on playing d
all right let's see
a lot of people want me to talk about
the arizona audit and uh
you know
obviously there's a bunch of super chats
throughout the show being like talk
about it talk about it talk about it
it's like i have to go through it and
like fact check it here's the thing
with a lot of stories like um
afghanistan
initially my assessment is based on
preliminary reports and then it turns
out like i didn't realize in the start
of the afghanistan withdrawal that we
abandoned bagram the way we did so my
assessment was like change and i was
like wait a minute i read this wall
street journal article look what they're
doing
here's the challenge with the az audit
as you probably already know the
mainstream media is not going to do a
fair assessment of what the details are
which means
this is one of the stories along with
many other that we actually have to have
our crew dig into and we're gonna do it
we're gonna we're gonna look into it um
that being said
my opinion is
you wanna we wanna know the easiest way
to make sure republican never wins again
is convince them all you can't win
and then they don't go out and vote
so you've got democrats going door to
door look at this way new york city how
many people live on one city block in
new york city
a lot a
now one the same distance in a rural
county how many people live in that same
distance one yeah two so when you're in
when you when you're in new york you've
got universal mail in voting and two
little democratic activists can say
we're gonna spend you know an hour on
one city block they can talk to a
thousand people
if the republican wants to go to a
suburban area one city block is going to
get them what 25.
so with universal mainland voting
denser population areas are
substantially easier for voter voter
turnout drives they knock on the door
did you vote yet you didn't there it is
fill it out have a nice day did you vote
yet republicans doing it serious
disadvantages yeah so i think you got
you got to focus on your ground game
your organizational powers and i'll tell
you this
whatever may be going on here
i think it's demoralizing people
i think the audits are great i think do
investigations build the trust but man
do conservatives need to get their
ground game going and libertarians to be
honest democrats have ground game dude
they know how to go door-to-door and
they have the advantage of population
density i think that plays the biggest
role and that's exactly why there was
such a major push for universal mailing
voting it's overt that's why they were
screaming when they said donald trump
was stealing mailboxes
because that is what gives them their
major advantage and it's not breaking
the rules it's like the law was changed
through universal mail in voting i had a
friend that did work the obama campaign
in 2012 and he said it was so incredibly
organized and effective and then he
worked the bernie sanders campaign in
2016 he said it was terrible so i have a
feeling it's not just democrats it's
this establishment exactly they know how
to run a machine
and and the establishment republicans
don't want trump or the populists so
they're like follow you
and it's it's much more difficult
all right immediate casualty care says
perfect a guest for the topic at hand as
well as a guy to learn from when it goes
wrong ed was kind enough to do an ig
review on our low profile trauma kits
asking for nothing in return a good man
who knows all things bad guy
yeah there you go yeah what is that what
was this uh it's a low-profile way to
carry around medical equipment you know
i mean it's
it's a scary time and i'm not you know
fear-mongering but it's a pretty good
idea to have at least some
basic knowledge uh and base and
materials to
stop somebody from bleeding out we have
like 30 medical kits here we had like
six and i was like tim can we get two
more and he bought like 20 yeah that's a
good idea uh well let's pass them out if
we need to 30 employees
we've got multiple acres animals it's
it's not it's a it's a weird thing like
it's people want to go and shoot guns
and and train how to fight with knives
and do all this stuff but they don't
want to learn how to plug holes
or yeah or like every now i do training
related to counter abduction and
everybody's like we're never going to
learn how to get a handcuffs that's
coming but first we need to talk about
narcan
right and first we need to talk about
roofies and how to flush your system and
how some why chemical restraints are a
thing so you do uh hostile environment
training stuff like that yeah
non-permissive environment training is
what i got what it's called i didn't
name it that's what that's the first
people that i started training here in
the state said ah that's not permissive
environments training okay
do you ever you ever get these like
really arrogant people
who are just like they think they know
more than you they think they're hot
stuff and they're gonna survive the
apocalypse
well you know
i get all types i get the
some people that are preppers that prep
but they
they can't you know run a mile yeah yep
uh i get the people that are really
worried about covet and they want to
wear a gas mask when they go outside but
they do just take some vitamins and you
know eat healthy and just you know run a
bit you know a little bit of that might
help you
i get all types i did i did a hustle
environment training and it was for
insurance purposes they made me do it of
course but i've actually you know i'd
actually been on the ground in a bunch
of civil unrest civil conflict and um
bor like i was in ukraine before it
erupted into like the separatist
fighting i was in uh venezuela which was
like probably the scariest where i had
to flee the country and so they made me
do this training and there was like a
weather guy there who was like trying to
give advice to people and i'm just like
like weatherman you can't tell this
woman what she's going to do when she
gets abducted and there's landmines i'm
sorry you have no idea what you're
talking about
one of the things i kind of struggled
with a lot of the stuff that i did was
like i i didn't go through seer training
or i wasn't part of the american
military a lot of my teachers were like
the first person i saw get out of
handcuffs and teach me how to get on
handcuffs was a 15 year old kid that was
a meth methuler right
um
the first person i saw that uh showed me
how to you know make something to cut
through zip ties with a kevlar cordage
was a fisherman was it when you were a
kid when you were younger not just
working and and meeting weird people
uh one of the things that i find like
the most like off-putting is people not
realizing the teachers are all around us
and they're not all going to wear a
green beret and been a military guy or
something like that most of the people
that know and study the craft of getting
around things are criminals
those are the best conversations i have
and if you don't if
if i go to a do a class and i start
talking about bribing a public official
and i can start getting like you can do
that
yeah i don't get it man you don't get it
we got scruples here you know it's
normal is a fluid concept
and you can't travel with your normal
that's the first red pill i give people
yeah
yeah man um egypt was certainly crazy
uh just like
when i tried talking to
here i'll tell you this here's a
challenge in the united states when i
was doing the heat training hospital
environment stuff uh someone asked
the guy running the course if
women should be worried about sexual
assault
and his reaction was to stutter and go
men can get raped
yes men it's like uh dude
see this is the problem in america they
can't say certain things because they
get sued for harassment or or treating
people you know not like you know not
like for
violating people's uh rights i guess
sensibilities yeah when you say like
there's a reality of that women you know
a guy will get killed and a woman will
get raped like when you when you're
dealing with a lot of these places
around the world and then when when i
have to deal with stuff like being in
egypt what the security company is going
to allow a woman to do versus what
they're going to amanda do you you
probably have every feminist in this
country screaming it's not fair yeah
there's a story about uh uh i could be
getting this wrong so just keep that in
mind
a reporter was was uh for fight with
vice was out and i think in algeria
and she was told not to go to the soccer
stadium because women aren't allowed and
she said i'm gonna do it anyway and she
got assaulted and then sued vice over it
even though the security people are like
you can't do that yeah but these they're
these people who think that algeria is
going to be like america yeah and they
don't realize like you walk in the wrong
neighborhood they should be like that's
a beating yeah they don't realize that
in egypt it's like you walk in the wrong
neighborhood like you're not covered up
and you're not here with your man you're
in trouble
the normal is a fluid concept you can't
travel with your normal you can't travel
with your bill of rights
that's an amazing thing also like seeing
americans in mexico doing like oh yeah
just uh this guy tried to put push me in
a van and i just stabbed him in the face
i'm just gonna wait for the police here
like
the that guy was probably i was a cop
[Laughter]
what do you recommend go to the embassy
not being allowed to not being able to
or two different things outside of the
united states
i mean
females
during training like i do
uh restraints or you know
handcuffs zip ties duct tape um show
people how to get out of that and also
how to you know manage some of that
stuff women always get more on them
because they're going to get it the
worst yep that's my way of treating them
differently now to be fair though we did
in our training do a scenario where we
got
surrounded at gunpoint yeah and all the
women were brought into a barn and then
the trainers told them and started
screaming you know bloody murder and
and then the guys outside are laughing
saying i think you know what we're doing
and stuff like that because he was
trying to make that point yeah so it
wasn't all overtly like you know trying
to avoid the realities of these things
do you have like we talked about basic
like natural rights in the united states
do you have that in mexico yeah but
nobody there's nobody to enforce them so
they don't exist really uh i mean human
rights are a thing in mexico
but usually they only involve people
that are you know have enough money to
kind of put them on their side there was
a
we support a small media group that we
work with called demolar it's on
instagram if you want to check it out
basically just cartel related news out
of mexico and it's all you know verified
by myself and other people that work
around it
uh there's a guy that stole a few candy
bars from the store and got placed into
a process uh a you know legal process
for three candy bars a very lengthy one
wow
and uh in the same vein there's a police
commander that was involved in the
massacre of 135 people or something like
that that is currently you know he just
has lawyered up and there's no problem
right and we did this comparison uh
if you have enough money if you have an
influence on hostile manner down there
and you know rights are a you know thing
to decide you can own a gun in mexico if
you're
upper middle class there's one gun store
in new mexico wow one gun store in
mexico it's a single gun store in mexico
city and the only way you can buy one is
you have to fly there
wow get a bunch of paperwork and buy an
overpriced underpowered caliber to be
able to defend yourself like what like a
22 at uh that of let's say uh
380 a 380 you can't get a nine
millimeter down there so that's a
military only
um so yeah low calibers horrible
horrible quality guns and they're all
it's a monopoly run by the military down
there and they then in their best
interest not to arm people so they make
it really hard speaking of guns dw says
tim did you see matt gates voted yes on
red flag laws 2a or bus sorry matt
you're no longer maga also
saveamericachat.com is number one for
america first discussion um if matt is
i'm going to look into that because that
is a big no-no red flag laws are bad bad
bad news they do not work the way people
think they do and if matt gates voted
yes on this it's exactly the problem we
have with republicans that's why i think
the republican party is garbage now
you want you want to look that up yeah
yeah looking it up oh yeah because i'll
all right now be like that's dumb so you
guys aren't familiar with red flag laws
i am yeah i am like yeah one day you're
at home and you get a knock on the door
and it's a bunch of cops being like
we're here to seize your firearms your
weapons and your like says who says this
warrant what are you talking about well
you're a danger to yourself for others
or they're ours now now that's not what
2a says
so the problem is you get no chance to
rebut for the most part if they came to
you and said we are going to make an
attempt at a seizure you have 30 days
you know here's your court date or
whatever still bad in my opinion because
it puts the burden on the on the
individual who has the right to keep and
bear arms but at the very least you'd be
able to go to the court and be like no
it's not true someone's made a false
claim against me and i will not stand
for this but these these things end
bloody yeah you're guilty someone gets a
medical marijuana card and now they're
no longer mentally safe someone jaywalks
now they're no longer mentally stable
like no red flag no this is they they
show up to a guy's house knock on the
door then the guy answers the door with
his gun which he legally owns and they
say we're taking your guns and he says
not from you know yeah for my cold dead
hands or whatever they fought the cops
killed the guy yeah that didn't need to
happen this is not a good idea to go to
americans who are like my cold dead
hands and instigate that kind of thing
and that's what you get you get
republicans whose position is i'll
compromise democrats and democrats say
give me everything or else
so instead of republicans being like we
want to repeal the nfa and all gun
restrictions they say
we're okay with some gun control and
then you end up moving further and
further into the gun control territory
as as a as somebody they're not from
here from my mind i'm from mexico of
course and uh there's no there's there's
there's a there's a part in the
constitution that allows for the
possession of and self-defense with guns
in mexico but there's a single federal
firearms law
that just that's that what deals with
everything everything firearms in mexico
you're not legally allowed to buy a gun
outside of the normal processes but
everybody has guns down there you know
new year happens and everybody's
shooting guns up in the air what's the
uh oh
no but main thing is
i've been in places where having a gun
is the difference between being targeted
and not being targeted
i've been in places where everybody that
has guns are having guns illegally
they're all criminals because they have
a gun
but
if they drop their guns if they get rid
of their guns the cartels are going to
run in and take their daughters right
there's a city uh luke talks about did
you do you remember that iran
there's no police there's no cartels
they kicked out the police because the
cartels were on the on the tank uh and
uh they armed themselves there's a
problem with some of these groups down
there like uh like there was a netflix
documentary on one of these uh auto
defensive groups that came up during the
mid 2000s
uh
they they're basically cartel groups
that now are being uh
guarding home you know they just switch
you know
t-shirts or sharon let me well let me
let me we got some of these groups we
got a super chat uh smashing random key
says how does sharon still exist how was
it even allowed to happen uh i mean it's
it's a small it's a very small community
and a lot of the weapons that they have
are
not the best weapons a lot of them were
stolen from the local police armory and
a lot of them are just hunting rifles or
things that have been trafficked there
like a few decades ago
uh the reason they're not they're being
left alone it's just it's too much of a
hassle and also they're too much in the
public eye right now so why why mess
with them but eventually they'll drop
out of the public eye
and influence will start seeping in
how they usually kill this group these
groups is that they can't
self-sustain
what happens when a bunch of extremely
wealthy bitcoin and caps start sending
resources so they can
self-sustain oh that would be amazing
well that's what we're hearing a lot of
yeah so when when this when this went
down you have a lot of people who are
like bitcoin millionaire and caps who
are like anarchy freedom no cartels no
government i'm their baby and they're
bringing their resources they're
bringing guns they're bringing security
i mean if that's one way another way is
basically just televising the revolution
giving them eyes yeah one of the main
problems that these communities have is
that they don't have eyes they don't
have a way to cast out their story their
their their reality
i got i get bombarded with pictures
videos and stuff like that from all
around mexico and they say dude ed
please post this i was like where's this
from this is from here okay just give me
enough i'll send it to the demo layer or
i send it to or i post it myself the
main thing is that
news coverage down there doesn't want to
put it up because it goes against the
government and that's not but that's not
good and up here they
don't care unless it's like something
specifically related or tied to the u.s
so main thing is giving these people
voices
give these people the ability to tell
their own stories and televise the
revolution if if they can figure that
out
getting them guns getting them bullets
is
only going to push them so far
really now says i have been at 20
different countries listening to
listening to you talk about racism is
accurate i have never experienced racism
more than in europe
definitely i'd say so
um particularly uh i i really it's i i
people probably don't want to believe it
but sweden man no joke i go to i go to
somewhere like france or the uk and it's
like okay there's racism yeah no you go
to sweden and it's like
extremely ethnically homogeneous
they pretend to not be racist but boy
are they racist they're i'm telling you
man i'm like in a car with a guy driving
into a black neighborhood and he's
shaking and freaking out being like
don't make me do this man and we're like
calm down what are we doing
we walk around the neighborhood
everything's fine
or it's like i should say like these
migrant areas a lot of muslims a lot of
somalis and we walk around it was like
there's there's nothing going on man
like go to chicago
and that guy would fall to the ground
and melt into a pile of jelly if you
went to chicago but it's it's
it's it's crazy to me but it's not just
about stuff like that it's about how
like they don't hire people they shuffle
them into these pocket communities where
they force them to fend for themselves
and then
it's just brutal man yeah i mean again
i've had some some weird experiences
here in the states that are not
specifically i mean just uncomfortable
now like uh somewhere in tennessee
somebody asked me if i was a christian
and i said yeah i'm catholic so you're
not a christian
and i was like okay and i said you know
i
i took it with humor because it's
humorous to me you know uh
but realistically a lot of the specific
hate that i've gotten in this country or
life specific like
discrimination has been by some of the
members of my own community mexicans
second generation third generation
people that call themselves latinx for
some reason yeah i was like okay
[Laughter]
i wonder if you did get mad when you say
those things i mean it's
do they i have to know yeah i mean it's
it's a it's a whole thing we're like
swearing the whole time yeah you just
you just talk you just you're talking
bad about mexico mexico is a beautiful
place like
what parts of mexico did you live in
yeah well i go down there to cancun and
go there it's like that's you know
mexico city is nice mexico city is nice
it's beautiful there's a lot of stuff
that happens in mexico city there's you
know and outside the outskirts of mexico
city are there's some pretty they all
that they got the pic people listening
to this they can tell me about some of
the places out there that are pretty you
know
have a lot of bad stuff happen
yes there's some beautiful places
there's some beautiful people and i'm
not i don't i'm not in a fight with the
people of mexico and i love the people
of mexico like this part of me doing
this and the stuff that i do is try and
give him voices and telling stories
about stuff that happens down there but
most of the hate that i've gotten
up here has been people are completely
detached from that reality
so
talking to the dad who is from mexico
like
what's the first thing you did when you
get out to his country i bought a gun
okay and then you talk to his uh you
know a grandson
what about you oh my dad's he has a gun
oh it's like oh guns kill people are you
like is that scary right aren't you
afraid that people having guns up here
like they have guns down there it's like
is that a foot and hole like that's a
beautiful thing you know yeah do the
cartels 3d print weapons
no
oh the reason i asked is because you
said in 2008 they were using these
advanced technologies drones i'm
wondering if they're not i haven't seen
a 3d print it doesn't make sense for
them
i've seen them being utilized a lot in
europe and stuff like that
though and
myanmar i think has
had some sub guns showing up 3d printed
mexico it has the largest the
commerce of firearms
in the world next to it so yeah and they
just the government actually just did a
government mexico just sued a bunch of
the firearms companies stateside oh well
because because of the guns that are
being trafficked yeah yeah seriously
enough they didn't sue sig sauer because
they're buying they're trying to buy
guns for the military that's interesting
i always tell people when they're like
aren't you scared when you go to these
countries like i haven't traveled in a
while but i used to fly i was on two
planes a week and i'd be like
no because people aren't crazy you know
this idea that you you have got like
kind of two camps of people you got
these people who think they can ride
their bikes to tajikistan and it's going
to be fine and then they get hit and
then isis jumps out and kills them it
literally happened and then you have
people who think you'll go to south
america and they'll drag you through the
streets and brutally beat you and i'm
like
yo
so some people believe stupid things and
and it drives them to do something but
that's not it's not like their behavior
isn't predictable what i mean is if
you're going to an area where you know
isis is dominant and you know what their
ideology is and you know what they're
looking for okay well then you're
probably going to be watching for that
you got to be careful but i was like
especially with with going to like
venezuela and brazil south america stuff
i'm like i know what
a general idea of these people's motives
especially when it comes to like gangs
cartels making money running a business
you don't interfere you don't bother
them you mind your own business you're
probably fine my favorite though is when
uh
we were in venezuela and they told me
like a very common thing one of the most
common things is express kidnappings
they'll pull up they'll throw you in
they'll drive you to an atm say take out
your money
and then you know they'll ditch you or
whatever but one guy told me a story
where he got express kidnapped and the
guys are armed they're putting a gun at
him and they're like they they're they
they you know driving to an atm they're
like take out all the money and he's
like i only have a couple you know
hundred whatever and then they're like
take it out they take it out and then
they'll get in the car and he's like
okay and they're like do you want a ride
man is there somewhere we can drop you
off he's like yeah i gotta go to work
and they're like yeah no problem let me
let us know where he's like yeah it's
around here thanks man and they're like
all right have a good one dude
like it's the craziest story you know
you think that like but after they get
their money they're just like we'll drop
you off now yeah hope everything's all
right it's a it's a thing i mean it's a
business it's a business it's a they're
human as well uh
they had this guy who was a cardiologist
he got abducted
uh he spent like two months in and they
did horrible things to him you know
basically wanted to convince his family
to pay up
um
when he was let go
uh
he was let go because we did something
and we found where he was being kept and
you know we we uh we encountered the
people that were holding him
uh
when we were debriefing him he kept
asking about the people that were
watching him because he was worried
about them
because these people you know
weren't specifically the ones
responsible for abduct him but they
weren't responsible to to look out for
him when he was yeah like they're being
forced to do a dog kendall then they had
set up for him
uh and he was like hey are they okay
like are they fine like like i was like
what and look stockholm syndrome
basically yeah uh they weren't fine none
of them were fine
and
he went into a weird depression because
of some of the stuff that happened to
them but it's a weird wow and again yeah
it's stories like that are
you know uh there's
my mom told me this long ago and it kind
of made things clearer for me
uh nobody's against you they're for
themselves exactly when you learn that
this this is basically what i mean when
i say people aren't crazy after
explaining this to them you you know
what if you know like what they're doing
and why they're doing it then
it's like they're not going to randomly
do things for the most part right they
don't want to put risk themselves they
want to get something out of you so
understand the motives of the person to
the best of your ability and then try
and navigate the situations and that
means you might like i had someone try
to pickpocket me in spain
they didn't succeed but i'm not about to
pick a fight with the guy who's probably
got friends around the corner operating
as their backup he comes up tries to
grab my phone fails and then i just back
away and yeah avoid the situation
because what they do is they'll have
someone waiting around the corner or
someone sitting down who's their spotter
in case a fight breaks out then they
jump you so it's like he failed it's
better that he's like my risk is too
high right now i'm going to walk and i'm
like and i'm not going to get into a
fight with him
yeah part of that that
normal is a fluid concept the lesson
that i give people is
you know i can walk around here with my
iphone but somewhere else that's going
to be a meal for a few weeks for
somebody i can walk around the gallery
yeah i can walk around here with my
earring but i'll you know go to brazil
and it's going to rip ripped off your
ear don't be a resource check yourself
make a travel debit card with a with a
with a prepaid travel debit card carry a
travel phone um carry a burner phone
that you can give out to somebody just
give out as a gift you know every now
and then i do security contracting jobs
and the first thing i do is i go to the
parking attendant with a major d or go
to the guy the guy that knows everything
and i give him a phone and a smartphone
that's worth probably like 150 or 200 on
ebay
and i get the best intel on the planet
there you know i just call him directly
when i'm done you can keep the phone
really yeah
yes key to the city yeah dude you know
but again it's it's weird to tell people
like ed so what can i make to defend
myself uh buy a phone give it to
somebody there make a friend yeah
friends that's awesome
yeah yep all right right on man well
it's uh it's been rad having you for
everybody else thanks for hanging out on
this friday night smash that like button
subscribe you can follow me at tim cast
you can follow the show at tim cast irl
make sure you check out
youtube.comcastcastle
we're going to a top secret location
this weekend which is going to be a
crazy vlog which probably be up on
monday maybe we'll see how it goes but
it's going to be a whole lot of fun like
i can't say too much we got to go and
film it first but uh is there anything
else you want to shout out website book
uh twitter check out my instagram
manifesto.com and check out our new
source demo layer on
instagram
demo lair demo there thanks for coming
man that was great thank you good love
you ed that was really really fun man
thanks thank you um lydia oh i mean
crossing by oh yeah are you telling me
right it's all about ed yeah there we go
okay yeah now that we know who ian is i
really appreciate ed coming a lot i feel
like i learned so much and i'm gonna
have to go back and watch your different
appearances on joe rogan as well i am
sour patch lids i push buttons in the
corner for a living thank you guys for
coming
man it's been great i think i'll have to
uh
um
you know i'll never forget that joe blew
that death whistle and it's all his
fault that's it can someone get him on
the horn yeah joe what have you done but
hey man it's been a blast and for
everybody else thanks so much for
hanging out and we will see you all at
the cass castle vlog over at
youtube.comcastcastle or timcast.com be
a member we got a huge library of condo
you can always go there and search our
massive list of podcasts with all of our
guests we got like a couple from steve
bannon we've got jack tons from jack
bosobic will chamberlain all this
awesome stuff so definitely check that
out and we'll see y'all next time bye
guys
you